Kept joining, huh?
Welcome to Metal Gear Solid 2's Substance!
Yippee!
Hello!
Oh, Shoujin-sama!
If it isn't saucy mint.
Oh my god, that actually works the most here.
Hold on, I'm going to turn it up because I love this theme a
little too much.
That girl always keeps you waiting.
Oh my gosh, let's watch the intro real quick.
PS2?
Yes, on my PS2, actually.
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh my gosh.
The saga continues.
This intro is so...
awesome oh my gosh it's so cool oh my gosh declaration of
independent wait is that the constitution or is that the
deco um david heyda
oh that would turn it up a little more
oh yeah oh Oh my gosh, she's so sexy.
Oh my gosh, I can't wait to play a snake the whole game.
Shut it for hail.
Yeah!
Why would Cam Clark be in this game?
We killed Liquid.
That's craziness.
Yes!
Yeah, that's my president!
Yeah!
I love that guy!
You didn't kill Liquid Fox died.
Oh, true.
You're right.
Wow.
Look at these soldiers.
Oh, oh, oh.
Harry Gregson Williams!
Yeah.
George Sears, my president.
Yo!
We're still living!
Whoa!
I voted for that guy.
Whoa, science!
Math!
Yay!
Oh gosh, I'm too excited.
Oh no, I'm too excited!
Yo, snack!
What, who that guy?
Oh, oh, snake!
Oh, who that guy?
Who, who that, who's that?
Who's that?
What a pretty lady.
Ta-da!
Oh my gosh.
Hold on, I'll put it at that.
She's kind of cute, huh?
Yeah, she's got nice hair.
Andregos, thank you for the 20 gifted.
Ronan, welcome back.
Serenine, welcome back.
Brendan, welcome back.
Hello, Mint.
Hello.
Hello, hello, hello.
Oh my gosh.
Remember when we did this on April 30th?
Yo, you remember what day it is tomorrow?
It's shredding time.
No, unfortunately, unfortunately we are not playing during
April, but that's okay.
That's okay.
That's fine.
Hold on, I'm going to turn up the volume just a little bit.
I might be adjusting it throughout the game.
eyes um but yeah uh welcome to metal gear solid 2 which is
i've gone back and forth so many times on if i really like
on if three or two is my favorite and even sometimes four
but truly i think two is my favorite out of all the metal
gear games i think i think two is my out of all of them i
think i true i like think about two the most i quote two the
most like it's just i used to be a hardcore like three is my
favorite that's why even i got the patchy slot but i say i
look at it longingly i love you patchy slot machine i love
you i have a confession i actually i didn't actually watch
most of your members member streamed live history.
I only hopped on to Superchat when people suggested I should
because it'd be funny.
Oh, good!
Wait, you don't know what was going on then, right?
Perfect.
Two is my favorite story, but five is my favorite gameplay.
I think that is most people, right?
Because five is like the best gameplay, right?
Save often multiple times in the same area.
Yeah, no reason.
He went back afterwards.
No!
I think Peace Walker is my favorite.
Oh, Peace Walker is so...
I love Peace Walker, too.
Peace Walker, I think, is so underrated.
It's so underrated.
I know 2 is, like, a fan favorite, for sure.
But I believe it's justified.
Everything about this game is, like, perfect.
everything about this game is perfect everything about the
series is perfect I love the series too bad Peace Walker
co-op is dead what are you talking about until we play
together baby what are you talking about you can always play
with Mito what about Rose she's perfect yes oh my gosh yes
if you have never played Metal Gear Solid 2 or watched
anyone play Metal Gear Solid 2.
Get ready for the soap opera, the drama of your life.
Oh, oh, it's so good.
Oh my god, I eat it.
Oh my god, it's so, the drama, the tea.
It's so good.
Oh my god, it's so awesome.
My favorite toxic relationship ever.
I love them so much.
I love, I just, Like, I can gush about everything in this,
in, in MGS2.
I can gush about everything in Metal Gear Solid, but I can
just...
Did I watch the VOD with a big grin?
Well, stop!
That's just sarcasm, right?
What are you talking about?
No, I'm being a hundred...
I'm always serious.
I like the part of when Solid Snake has to steal the
Declaration of Independence.
I know.
Where do you think they got that movie?
from nicholas cage is supposed is is solid snake watch me to
play mgs2 do it yourself i could but i could just gush about
everything in this in this game in particular i think it's
like the perfect balance of serious and goofy and like mind
mind everything mind mind spending yeah just too good oh oh
it's so good this game is so good i love it mind-blowing yes
are you richard ames you must be ames it's so great so it's
just oh it's just so good oh i can't get over it i'm so
excited to be playing it again it's also a game that i like
pretty much fumble my way through I'm not very good at this
game.
So I'm prepared for comments of being like, gosh, Min-to is
not very good at this game.
But that's, it doesn't matter.
I have heart.
I love this game so much.
So it doesn't matter.
Vituber, why?
Why Vituber?
Why do you love game but you bad at it?
MGS 2 is the one I'm worse at too.
I think it like, because going from MGS 1 to this game, it
introduces...
It introduces probably an overwhelming amount of mechanics
that are not in MGS1.
But in like a good way.
It's just...
I wish I could have played this as a kid.
Because I would have been like...
Actually, you know what?
I don't think as a kid I would have appreciated how...
How...
Uh...
Advanced this game was.
You know?
I think I wouldn't...
I think I wouldn't appreciate it.
I appreciated it as a kid.
Did you really?
Did you say, wow, this is doing feats and technical
advancements?
Okay, but I did feel that way about, like, Kingdom Hearts
cutscenes.
I was like, wow, Kingdom Hearts cutscenes look amazing.
They look like the best ever.
Try to remember the basics of CQC.
No, there's no CQC here!
I don't think Raiden VR's VR mission CQC does he?
If you're not good, a tip.
Get the thermal goggles.
Little kid got me filtered by vamp.
Too scary.
Really?
I didn't really care for this game as a kid because it was
so different.
It definitely aged good though.
That's the thing about this game is it aged perfectly.
It can still be played now and be such a good kid.
I think Yusei was censored by the patrons I never played
this game till much later but I remember watching a friend
played the first few hours when it was new and this game has
always been unbeatably cool I know make sure to bring garlic
happy 37th anniversary to Metal Gear Vito yeah cool you're
doing a playthrough on PS2 we got it re-releases but it's
nice to check out the OG platform yeah so I am playing this
on my PS2 I'm looking at my baby over and um yeah so someone
who played mgs1 is a youngin i couldn't even keep up with
the character's names i'm trying to think yeah like i i
don't think i mean i kept up with kingdom hearts so i
probably could have done the same for this why is there
skateboarding why isn't there skateboarding why wouldn't
there be skateboarding Do you have a slim?
I have a slim.
Slim, slim.
Skinny legend.
Story became more and more relevant as the years went on.
Have fun.
Thank you!
I was so excited.
Happy birthday.
Congratulations.
Happy birthday with salutations.
Happy birthday.
May your sky stay blue.
Happy birthday to you.
Okay, I don't want to take up too much time because I can
literally just talk about this game forever.
So we're going to...
New game!
And I have it in the pinned comment, but I will say just in
case again, please, no spoilers in the chat.
I will do my best as well.
I will do my best, but please no spoilers as much as you can
in the chat.
I know we all get very excited.
But just for anybody who is following along in the series
for the first time.
We just spoiled a lot, though.
No, we didn't.
Had a ton.
Vamp kills Dumbledore.
Yeah, so.
Just do your best, you know.
I sometimes, you know, I'm not perfect either.
I'm pretty perfect, but I'm not perfect.
I'm pretty perfect.
But you know.
Tanker plant.
What if I just skip the tanker?
Wouldn't that be horrible?
Wouldn't that... What if I... Who is skipping the tanker?
I get it.
You just want to get into the game.
But it just makes me so sad.
To my eyes!
Thanks for the five, Gryfft.
Thank you.
Do it.
No!
It's messed up.
Speedrunners?
No.
A true speedrunner would play the whole game.
Okay.
Where do you guys think it's going to start?
I have five bucks on the Hudson River.
We're going to play on normal.
And radar type 2.
Radar off.
Am I a psycho?
Radar and sons of liberty will not appear at all.
This story is fictional, everybody.
Any similarities to me?
Or just similarities?
The Hudson River.
Two years ago.
You guys all owe me $5.
He had classified intelligence that a new type of metal gear
was scheduled for transport.
The whole thing stank.
But our noses have been out in the cold too long.
No!
Let me meet the Platonic, of course.
Size.
Oh my gosh, thank you guys for holding your side of the
agreement.
Appreciate it.
Okay, that's enough.
Thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
Lolly Lulule low tax.
How's the audio?
You win.
Thank you guys, thank you.
Who's that?
I recognize that gray blue.
We have to give five dollars?
That's good.
Just checking if Streamlabs notifications are enabled.
Yes, they are!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Five bucks.
A bed is a bed.
Thank you.
Thank you for your first ever super chat.
Oh, oh he's running.
Oh, he's running.
Wow, he's taking off.
Oh my god.
Um, he is...
Oh, it's kind of loud.
He's got superpowers.
Oh my god!
Who is that?
This is my actually least favorite part of the game because
I'll show, I'll tell you in a second.
What it had is zero!
Cliff!
Thank you.
Whoa!
Are you okay there?
Oh my god.
He's like flipping them.
You alright?
Oh!
Be careful.
Whoa!
Harry, Gregson, Williams.
I'm a twin IRL.
You are?
Wow!
That's my least favorite part of the game.
Because now we don't have the stealth camouflage anymore.
Why is your technology so faulty?
Oh my god, it was Solid Snake the whole time!
Um...
Oh!
Oh no, soon enough.
Oh my gosh, it's us a lot!
Spinning his little gun as usual!
Yeah!
So cinematic, so awesome, so iconic!
This is Snake.
Do you read me, Otacon?
Loud and clear, Snake.
Kept you waiting, huh?
I'm at the sneak point.
Everything going okay?
Yes.
Kiss.
We must have overused it.
Sorry, but you're gonna have to deal with it.
You're not in the military anymore.
Right.
I didn't plan on relying on this gadget anyway.
Sounds quiet.
The private sector is not so bad, is it?
Privacy guaranteed?
I'm happy as long as no one gives me any more unwanted
gifts.
He said the thing.
And I can't say I missed the chattering nanny.
Maybe you call her a nanny.
I have to get in touch with her again about that new Natick
flash.
How's it now?
Is it better?
Diverting toys from the SSCEN again?
Give her a message from me.
Someone will find out sooner or later.
She's better off assuming it's sooner.
and quit while she's safe too true okay snake let's get to
work a million year you know how the technical specs of
metal gear were sold on the black market after shadow Moses
all Ocelot's doing and now every state group and dot-com has
its own version of metal gear not exactly a classified
weapon for today's nuclear powers this new one seems to have
been designed to wipe the floor with all the other models
the only consistent description is an amphibious anti-metal
This one is under Marine Corps jurisdiction.
Not in million years.
The mission objective is to make visual confirmation of the
new metal gear being transported by that tanker and bring
back photographic evidence.
Okay, we can do that.
But I want you first to go up to the top level of the
infrastructure, to the bridge.
We need to find out where the tanker is headed.
A little reconnaissance, huh?
There's too much we don't know about this new prototype.
New capabilities, deployment method?
We don't even know how close it is to completion.
If we know where the testing arena is, I can start to draw
some reasonable conclusions.
Alright.
I'll head to the bridge, ASAP.
ASAP.
Try to avoid confrontations.
Our goal is to collect evidence on Metal Gear development
and expose it to the world.
It would be best if you could get out of there without
alerting anyone.
Don't worry.
I know the drill.
Very good.
Don't you forget that you're part of philanthropy.
Philanthropy!
An anti-Metal Gear organization and officially recognized by
the UN.
but still fringe Otakon I love snake he's so silly all right
let's look at your gear your weapon is a tranquilizer gun
converted from a Beretta M92 M9 it's a little hard to work
with because you have to reload after each shot since the
slide locks better than scavenging at the mission size the
chemical stun will take effect in a few seconds and last for
hours you can take down and Phantom Deaths.
Ha ha ha.
First, first, first person shooting!
Between hitting limbs, chest, head.
I like that they show that you can blow out the light.
As for the equipment.
Hey, Snake, cigarettes?
What's wrong with you?
It's kind of a lucky charm.
I gotta eat them.
You haven't read the Surgeon General's warning, have you?
The rain is sound is so loud.
It works almost the same way as your old one.
I never picked up the camera before.
Like I didn't pick it up last time I played.
Yummy cigarettes!
I'm just need a little snack.
It's like my calorie mate.
I'm gonna take out that guy.
Hey, Earth to Snake.
These are nice upstanding Marines, not terrorists.
I'm not gonna take out these guys.
You're in stealth mode here.
Sure, and if it comes to that, a little beauty sleep never
hurt anyone.
Or a little eternal sleep.
Are you sure of this intelligence?
Absolutely.
Hacked it out of the Pentagon's classified files myself.
No traces.
Oh, please.
I'm too good for that.
I can't speak up.
I can't hear you over the rain.
There's a price on our heads.
You're just being paranoid.
I hope so.
Those men.
You wouldn't think they were anything but civilians for
fear.
I'm into eternal sleep.
It's not that bad.
With all the ships passing on the river and in the harbor,
putting uniform Marines on the deck would be a bad idea.
People can get a clear view of the water from riverside too.
Who's getting a clear view at this time of night?
This type of weather.
According to the navigational plans, this ship should have
discharged its cargo upriver.
It's in there, no doubt about it.
The military trains you to watch for threats from the stern
on board.
Also, how huge is this thing to have a metal gear on it?
You worry too much.
Where's the target?
The satellite surveillance is a major international pastime
these days.
Maybe see it?
No.
Do you see the entrance to the holds?
Looks like there are a few entryways into the crew quarters.
Okay.
Oh no, no, my upstanding Marines!
No!
Not the upstanding Marines!
Looks like we're not the only ones after Metal Gear tonight.
Is that a chopper I just heard?
Affirmative.
Probably another cavalry.
Now I can kill them.
It's their game.
Hijack?
They're probably targeting the ship's controls.
How many men do you need to take over a tanker of this size?
A ship is run by a computer, so I'd say about 18 people.
That sounds so small.
That sounds so not enough people for a ship this size.
They're next.
They look weak.
Snappable.
You sure?
There's just a smuggleless map with somebody's stomach.
Dang, Snake, you're so gentle.
Just because his hair isn't long and luscious like your
mullet.
Oh, it's the hat.
Maybe you should have been like the hat, not the hair.
Why does Snake look so sussy?
The slow turnaround is so funny.
Oh, they just took it.
K-60 Kasatka.
Kasatka.
Kasatka?
chopper right killer whale coffee or tnt on who they are
judging by their transport aren't they some but i'm drinking
coffee right now not necessarily it could be the ka62 the
civil model look snake all we need is the photographic
evidence of metal gear as long as we have those we can put
it online and blow the whole thing wide open so no
pyrotechnics okay all right What?
This isn't like Shadow Moses.
I see.
Reach me if anything happens.
The frequency is 141.12.
What?
How can I check in and save my progress?
I'll do it.
There's a frequency set aside for it.
How can I save my progress?
140.96.
Sorry, but no Mei Ling this time.
Oh, yeah.
Call me on the codec when you want to save.
Right.
Got it.
I'll be waiting just past the Verrazano Bridge.
I'll get right on it.
You need to be off that ship by then.
I'll be in touch.
Oh!
It's me.
I'm playing now.
It's me, everybody.
Welcome.
Let's see.
We got our camera.
We got our AP sensor.
We got our cigarettes, our snack.
Let's see.
We got...
Oh yeah, our M9.
Minto Gaming.
Let's see.
Let's uh...
Let's call Otagon.
Push the action button near a scalable railing to hang off
the other side.
This is called hanging.
You can use it to move around, hide, and even maneuver
around an enemy's back.
You can move left and right while hanging by moving the left
analog stick or using the L2 and R2 buttons.
It's called hanging.
When you're ready to pull yourself up, just push the action
button again.
It's called hanging.
A grip gauge appears below the life gauge during hanging.
The grip gauge indicates how tightly you're holding on and
steadily decreases as long as you're in hanging mode.
Thanks for the brave.
We just started Metal Gear.
you won't be able to hold on we just started welcome
yourself up before you fall off push the crawl button while
hanging to jump down straight below if the ground is too far
below you'll lose some life in some places you won't make it
wrong be careful of that yippee yippee yippee yippee
murphy thanks for the gift aid and let's save real quick too
can we just see how you want to save diane and montreal
thank you see you there Raymack, thanks for the five gifted.
I tested it earlier, so if you see this file, it was just me
starting up the game and making sure everything worked.
So I'll just save right over it.
There we go.
Ducky, thanks for the gifted.
Snake, you of course know the saying, one for all, all for
one?
Yeah.
What is this all of a sudden?
Oh, I figured you'd need a lot of motivation, so I came
prepared.
It's from the three musketeers.
book not the candy bar anyway it means that if you go up
against everyone by yourself they'll gang up on you too i
think i think since you're on your own on that ship you need
to take this to heart and avoid confrontations how is that
just like the old days huh he's so cute almost reminds me of
melee but you sure you got it right of course what's with
this track you can count on it great
Next scene, thank you for the 10 gift, Cooper, thanks for
the 5.
Thank you so much, you guys.
Thank you, thank you.
What's with this guy?
Ah, Pitoki!
Thank you for the 50 gift!
Thank you so much.
What's with this guy?
Alright, let's see.
How do I press square button to aim, released with fire.
Alright, so we're gonna test that out with the lights here.
And then I go into this mode, that's right.
it all right it's gonna come back to me eventually where's
the lights oh i can take this one out oh wait wait how do i
where's the light coming from phew there we go phew and phew
Oh, I'm one here too.
Oh.
Shoo.
Scourge.
Thanks for the gifted.
Wait.
Is there a guy here?
Oh.
Our sleepy friend?
Um.
Let's see.
Alright.
This game terrifies me.
I'll be honest.
It's so...
Like I said earlier.
the level oh shit oh my god oh my god oh oh i should
probably be um looking at my radar the the the level
difference from the first game to the second game just like
jumps immensely i believe and so it kind of frightens me
just a little bit where'd he go anyway
grip level two for oticon boyfriend praise wait actually
How do I...
Oh, there we go.
Grip level one!
Oh, wait.
La la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la.
Snake has such good grip.
Unlike a certain other person.
La la la la la.
How do I do the pull-up?
Oh, you need to do pull-ups.
How do I do it?
Ah!
Snake, respond.
Snake, snake!
Uh.
That's how you do it.
That was a pull down.
No!
All the lights are back on.
This bozo's awake again.
Okay, okay.
There we go.
Oh, okay.
do it that was a dive oh l2 r2 whoo whoa it's going down so
fast oh holy oh i'm working out i'm working
Hey, look at him.
He's just showing off at this point.
Everybody, two pull-ups together.
Getting his reps in.
A hundred!
No way.
Okay.
We can do this.
You can drop down and catch to another ledge.
Oh, but then I have to, like, go up there, you know.
It's okay.
We're probably at, like, 50.
We're probably at, like, 60 now.
We're probably 70, 71, 72, 73.
74.
I actually have no idea what we're at.
Come on, Sig!
Your stamina, your stamina, man.
I like how this doesn't even like do anything because we're
gonna be, you know, later on.
This will mean nothing to us.
Totally somewhere around 100.
armless yeah later on we'll be armless so sad so sad I'm
never done this before like even in my past times that I've
played so I I'm curious do you mean unarmed no armless I
wonder what we're at come on snake probably at like 99 100
good boy
we're so close that's why next to the 10 gifted anyway this
is a Zatin now we're just yapping about anything oh my god
oh my god
That was close.
What is this super jet?
Sick gains.
Ring fit stream.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
You okay, Snake?
You all right?
Did I make it to level two?
Is that what that meant?
Nope.
Ah.
Anybody keep the gap?
Um, I have been.
99, 100.
I did half a pull-up.
Let's go.
Let's go!
You guys, Cole is, um, beating everybody here.
How many pull-ups have you guys done?
Snake has done 2,000 at this point.
One focuses on the main path.
Subsequent runs are for the goofy things like this.
We're gonna get peed on!
Wait, is Snake losing health?
No.
Snake, don't lose health.
Zero.
We're gonna get peed on.
We're gonna, um...
We're gonna meet, um...
bisexual people.
I mean, we've already met, too.
We're gonna...
What else happens in this game?
We're gonna experience a dud.
Lots of things are gonna happen.
Oh my god, please!
How many more?
You are at 60 now.
Wait, actually?
I will turn on D.
DVR just so someone can count.
I did.
67.
80.
Oh my god.
You get fat in this game?
We laugh and we get fat.
It's kind of awesome.
It's so funny.
You know?
Every time I laugh, I get a little fatter.
I think I'm in trouble.
I don't know if some of these are counting.
What am I at?
Oh my goodness!
I'm overweight because of you.
Look, just stop, just stop laughing.
Most probably didn't count?
No way.
Don't say that.
This counts.
I think it counts if I, if it goes faster, right?
It should count if I go, if the, if the thing, if the gate,
okay, I'm done with this.
I'm sorry.
90 already, I think?
Okay.
I'm trusting you, Shiki.
We're gonna do 10 more.
Two.
You're so close, boss.
If laughing makes you fat, our wisps, our wisps lean because
we cry so much.
You need more, you need to intake so much more salt because
you cry so much.
One.
Two.
Three!
I think you just hit 90?
They were off by 10?
Oh my god.
Okay, 10 more.
One!
Two!
Three!
Four!
Five!
One!
Two!
Three!
More!
Five!
Ten more.
If not, read this message again.
Oh, I give up.
Where is that guy?
Oh, that was weird.
Okay, I have to press down pretty.
Good night.
Good night, sweet Chris.
Yeah, we don't need a level 2 anyway, I guess.
I'll try it somewhere else.
One thing I do want to improve upon in this, if I can, is
holding people up, shooting radios, stuff of the like.
Is that a guy there?
And then there's this guy over here, right?
Where is he at, anyway?
He's not going to see me.
He's going to go north and then...
Make a pause.
Express, are you okay?
Are you okay, buddy?
Thank you for the super chat.
Most scamblers give up before reaching.
Oh, he doesn't even come over here!
Can I get him?
Oh, shoot.
Uh...
Oh, he didn't even...
Idiot, didn't even notice.
What if I get him again?
Am I even shooting his body?
I can't even tell.
Maybe I'm hitting the wall.
I can't tell.
Oh!
Good night!
Oh, um...
Uh, okay.
Oh, here we go.
La, la, la, la, la.
I'm gonna throw him overboard.
How do I do that?
Scourge, thanks for the gifting!
How do I throw him overboard?
He's not giving me anything good.
Oh, there!
Okay, now he definitely deserves to go overboard.
Oh, the gate, that's right.
This way!
This way, buddy, you're going into the box!
The box!
You're going to the box!
There you go!
Good night.
Is there anything over here?
Just so good!
Thank you for that, because I won't scatter your sorrow to
the heartless...
You know, just...
You know.
Just, uh...
My bad.
I'm not.
I'm not scattering here.
I won't.
I won't do...
I...
I won't do it
This guy show up over here Maybe not Oh he's asleep Let's um
Take it Oh he's got three still but We'll just give him a
little extra boost What do you have for me Mr. If you have
nothing You're going to the gate Okay You got it?
A gate!
To the gate, to the gate, to the gate, to the gate, to the
gate, to the gate, to the gate, to the gate, to the gate, to
the gate, to the gate, to the gate, to the gate, to the
the gate, to the gate, to the gate, to the gate, they're
going to the gate, to the gate, to the gate, to the gate, to
the gate, To the gate.
Have mercy!
I lied.
I'm a vengeful ghost.
Donk donk donk donk donk donk donk donk donk donk.
Wait, where's the staircase?
All over here.
I think?
Yeah.
His forehead.
Fine.
I'm committing murder.
To the gate.
to the gay you're going to the gay have a safe trip see you
next fall to the ocean you go okay I gotta go I'm what we're
saying it was so important oh snake go through that door
into the ship's interior okay action button down in front of
the door and wait until the door opens before letting go
okay If you need to open the door faster, hit the action
button repeatedly while you turn the handle.
Got it.
Make sure you keep doing it until the door is open.
Thanks, Otacon.
Actually, what if I...
One.
Two.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Okay.
Push-ups?
No, pull-ups!
One.
Now we can fall down.
Three.
Look at the butt.
The ashes.
MGR ashes.
What's going on?
Come on, Snake.
How's your day been, Minto?
It's been all right.
I woke up kind of late
but I woke up Matara and I were supposed to record for the
podcast so we were going to record the Patreon episode and
she was like we were going to record at 11 a.m.
EST she we ended up not recording until 1 because she fell
back asleep
so yeah Rip Mata.
Rest in pieces.
I don't...
Are we ever going to get grip level 2?
I don't believe this is real.
I'm going in.
Next pull-up for sure.
I remember there's a guy that goes down here, right?
Does he come through here?
Actually, I don't remember.
We'll wait.
Oh no, he just kind of...
I can't go in here.
Oh!
Jackpot!
Ah!
This reminds me of when we first met.
I was the one inside the locker that time.
We're equal now, huh?
Not unless I wet my pants.
That's a low blow, snake.
That's a long blow, Snake.
Push the action button once more to get out of the locker.
You can see out from the slit in the door.
Make sure you check the area using first-person view before
you go out.
If you open the locker, you can use the door as a cover
during an exchange of gunfire.
But, of course, this is a pretty flimsy door.
how many bullets it can withstand.
Don't count on it too much, okay?
That was a kiss?
Oh.
Why is...
Otacon, come on, say the thing.
We'll take a photo.
Okay.
Push the action button.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's right, it's gotta be a photo.
Whoa.
Oh.
Wait, why won't it let me open up my menu?
Do I have to...
Wait.
She's so cute!
There we go.
Maybe I'll let me now?
Unless I do it here.
Oh, yeah, baby.
Wait, how do I take it?
Oh, square.
What do you think, Otacon?
What do you think you're doing, Snake?
You don't have enough to keep you busy?
Try to remember the mission if you can.
What do you think you're doing, Snake?
You don't have enough to keep you busy?
Try to remember the mission if you can.
Otacon!
What do you think you're doing, Snake?
You don't have enough to keep you busy.
Try to remember the mission if you can.
Shut it.
You and your hyperactive libido.
Oh, sorry.
I can't stop staring at this girl's...
Sorry, madam.
Russian!
Oh,
I haven't been gifting the last two times you got gifts.
Liquid scourge.
Oh, oh my god.
I don't know why they never open up for me.
Oh, oh, no, no.
Okay, we're good.
We're still good.
Hello?
Open up.
What's inside?
Anything?
Anything of use?
Oh, oh.
That's so cool that you can, like, even do this, you know?
That's so fun.
Good night.
Sweet princess.
The last one has a poster too?
This one?
Ah!
Wah!
Kasha!
What do you think you're doing, Snake?
You don't have enough to keep you busy?
Try to remember the mission if you can.
I'm sorry!
Her face is up here.
She does have a really beautiful face.
Wait, where's my other picture?
Oh, oh, oh, sorry.
I can't stop taking them.
My butt.
I overwrote it, I did.
No.
Here, we'll overwrite this one.
Sorry, I'm still trying to get used to the commands.
Because they're different from the first.
There we go.
Still too close?
Why am I too close?
Step back.
I'm getting the goods!
What are you talking about?
Okay, okay.
Hold on.
Let me shut this door.
Lovely, lady.
Good.
See those lockers?
That's a good place to hide yourself if you're in a pinch.
Push the action button near the wall.
Locker to open the door.
Walk in with a quick concealment.
Push the action button once more to get out of the locker.
You can see out from the slit in the door.
Make sure you check the area using first-person view before
you go out.
You can also hide enemies you've knocked out in the locker.
I love doing that!
Just open the locker, then drag the body to the locker.
Then they'll be asleep.
Let's set this one, too.
Let's get another perfect picture.
overwrite this one.
Good.
Oh, there it is.
Yes, Snake, I know.
My photography is impeccable.
Scary.
Nice roll of thirds.
Thank you.
Just gonna...
I gotta learn how to hold these guys up.
You don't look very comfortable, mister.
I'll help you, I'll help you, come here.
Oh, yeah.
This is the best angle of the game.
Hey, give me your stuff.
To the gate?
No!
Oh, thank you!
Do not knock on the posters when you lean on them.
Wait, what do you mean?
What do you mean by that?
Come here.
You're going into the closet.
You're going into the closet!
Not with the sexy lady though, she's mine.
This one.
Sorry, you don't get a view.
Come here.
In you go.
Good night.
What about this one?
Wait.
The other poster?
Yeah, I'm on it.
Move your hand over the center.
Sensitive!
Snake!
Oh, this goes outside.
Could have caused an alert if the guard wasn't knocked out.
No!
Oh!
I like how erratic the the camera angling is.
It feels like I'm really playing.
So there's that guy.
Cool.
Thank you, Nixidawa, for the membership.
Okay, there's the two of them.
I thought there was a guy upstairs.
Am I...
Silly?
Maybe I'm silly.
I think if I get him...
Um...
When he's over there, he doesn't notice.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, uh...
What the hell?
Stop turning!
Oh, my God.
Um...
What?
What am I gonna do with you?
I'm just gonna put him over here, I guess.
What do you give?
What kind of snacks do you have?
Put in the sexy lady post, the blocker?
No!
That's my heaven!
That's my place!
Oh.
Pepe!
To be honest, I don't quite remember where to go.
I remember.
Like, I need to...
There's a bomb.
I remember...
Oh, there's that guy's shadow right there.
I remember where I need to go because we need to fight Olga.
Going up.
Yeah, to Olga.
I see him there.
Is this where I...
I'm supposed to...
I'm
afraid I'm not gonna hold this guy up.
Oh.
Otacon!
I'm scared!
Hold my hand!
Did you say that locker was your outer heaven?
In some locations, the lighting makes your shadow longer and
more noticeable.
This cave is so scary!
The enemy might spot your shadow, so you want to watch out.
are especially dangerous.
I know.
But the same holds for the enemy.
If you spot someone's shadow ahead, you can avoid
unnecessary risks.
This game is so advanced!
Just walk, just get past the corner and hold him up.
So I just like walk up and I just go, I just go, freeze.
Right?
But how do you, I don't remember actually, how do you run
with the, um, gun i can't remember l1 to move a name
oh thank you what if i go up like this freeze freeze oh oh
shoot oh um it didn't work
um dang it uh you have to pull the gun up oh so i come at
him and then i go and then i pull it up Flawless!
Okay, again.
The commands in this one are still a little a little a
little for me, you know what I mean.
So if I...
Okay, hold on.
She's not gonna see me, right?
You'll get the hang of it, I believe.
Oh.
Hold on, I'm gonna wait for her to come back.
Sorry, I'm being a baby because I want to get used to the
controls again.
Foxy is still in Pirates Go.
So if I do this...
Freeze!
Yeah!
And then I...
Shake for me, baby!
Shake for me!
me.
Shake for me a little bit.
Yeah!
Shake for me!
Okay.
Thank you.
Good night.
Oh, we got some chaff grenades.
Oh, wait.
Do I have to put the do I have to open this up first?
I think so.
Hold on.
Oh.
Oh, I gotta get the usps first.
Oh, no!
I guess we'll never get the usp, but that's okay.
Or we'll never... Oh.
Oh, what the...
Oh, I did just see a rash in there.
Oh my goodness.
Let's go this way.
Does this go up?
Yes.
Oh, wait, what's... This goes outside.
Ew, it's what?
Oh, no!
We gotta go to the other side.
Just kidding.
It's only got two, so...
Good night.
Too late for all the dog tags.
No, I don't focus on stuff like that, you know.
I just kind of like to chill and have fun with the game.
I'm not focusing on getting all the dog tags or anything
like that.
So getting all the dog tags is the worst.
Yeah, I don't...
Really eat.
K or two?
So...
One more super before I eat.
Please go to sleep.
I forgot how I got here, but I'm glad I never left.
Ah, thank you!
Did I get it?
I don't think I got it, did I?
No, it's... how...
How did that not work?
Oh.
Oh, it's a triangle.
That's right.
Oh, I have a... I have a, you know.
I don't have a, you know...
It's fine.
We're sneaking past.
We're very sneaky.
More chaffs.
Yeah, I do have a chaff.
Oh!
Oh, my favorite angle, baby!
My camera is asleep now.
Relatable.
Okay.
I think it's up here that I'm thinking of.
Surveillance camera.
All the rations.
Oh my gosh.
Scared the heck out of me.
How many rations do I have?
I don't even know.
Oh, come on, I'm scared.
Snake, those pipes you see along the wall and ceiling are
steam conduits.
They're thin enough to penetrate with gunfire.
Don't touch the steam.
One of those blasts from the hole will burn your skin.
skin off.
Blast from the hole?
You may be able to use it as a trap of some sort, though.
Ooh.
Loticon, I'm saving.
Do you want to save, Snake?
Yeah.
Boiled.
Yeah, burn someone else's skin off.
Yeah, we're going to boil.
We're going to boil the soldiers.
Also, do you love that it's January 1st, 2000?
Okay.
There's a saying that goes, even a bird on high dies a
glutton's death as do the fish of the deeps the lesson is uh
don't be greedy i don't the fish that belonged to a family
called the deeps died from the deeps and so did a bird that
got high on something probably fermented fruit okay if you
say so i do he just believes it don't take unnecessary risks
just because you're greedy for more items remember the deep
family's fish
all right buddy yeah you you yeah yeah whatever you say man
i love it it's so cute do they come back in here i can't
remember remember the family fish everybody snake is just
like okay this
isn't where the bomb is is it oh it is it is where the bomb
is Oh my gosh!
Wait, then I can get the box in here, right?
Oh, I missed it.
Sorry, Otacon.
I'm getting a box.
Yippee!
I'm an orange!
I'm an orange.
Just an orange!
Maybe I can hold them up afterwards.
Okay, I'm gonna do my best.
Actually, I know I'm gonna mess it up.
I'm scared.
Sleepy time?
Sleepy down.
What is this?
Oh, nice.
Um, where are you anyway?
Oh.
Shoot the flower.
Does it actually do anything?
Just putting you right over here.
From sleepy to like...
You ain't waking up, sleepy.
Snake, wait.
Don't move.
Oh!
I see it.
Some kind of device on both sides of the hall.
Infrared sensors.
Right, and they're linked to...
Let me guess.
Semtex!
Not Semtex!
If you trip the sensors, I'll be sleeping with the fishes
along with this entire ship.
Oh my god, the deep fishes!
That sounds about right.
Hmm, there aren't that many infrared beams.
Maybe you can get past those without setting off the
explosives.
If you need to see exactly where the beams are, you can use
the usual method.
My cigarettes?
There's a fire extinguisher over there.
Break it open and try scattering some of the extinguishing
chemicals.
A lot of cotton's having me be all, you know, healthy and
such.
And does this guy come over here?
Oh my god.
Ah!
What if I do?
Do I show- Ah, I can't see anything!
La la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la
la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la.
Give me your stuff!
Your little weeny!
I'm putting you in jail!
Oh, never mind.
I don't wanna go out there.
Hey, give me your stuff.
Make him trigger the bomb.
I'll die too with him.
Will I not?
No alerts!
Let's go!
You will.
Word!
You guys just want to see me dead.
I'm already dead, though.
Amazing, you're the best!
it pretty safe though.
I played it pretty safe though.
The Kasatka!
They upgraded from the Hinde.
Can't please!
I hope there's at least one hot lady amongst them.
It's raining men.
Hallelujah.
Oh good thing we got inside before uh they were like spying
on us a front eve
we're suffering severe lack of girl boss right now it's true
it's true
i need a lady who's not god sorry i can't stop looking at
his butt i need a lady who's not gonna treat me right snake
did you find out where that ship is headed no looking at it
35 degrees longitude latitude around 58 more than 500 miles
off the coast of the Bermuda's out in the middle of the
Atlantic so the prototype is ready for solo testing I
understand it's basically combat worthy that area is outside
where you going on it's operational range too but it must be
a standalone Marine Corps project which means this prototype
they look really sneaky right now independent deployment
without any naval assistance anyway look like they're
Crouching.
Analysis can wait till later.
Snake, you need to go down to the hole to locate the actual
metal.
Ah!
What was that?
Nothing here.
Oh!
Oh.
Where do I get the usp from?
Do I get it after this fight?
Don't worry, we're gonna trank her though.
Where'd she go?
Pretty lady.
Oh no, she's hooy.
Hot even.
You can't get it before the spy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, let's...
What if I go up this way?
Dang it.
Okay, game.
I understand.
I understand what you're putting down.
Hooy!
Oh.
Shallashasca!
We know that guy!
Report your status.
Control room, communications and engine room are under
control.
All entry and exit points to the tanker hold secured.
Infrared sensors placed and operational.
Operational.
Good work.
Are the explosives in place?
Explosives?
Yes, they are all planted.
Listen, once we have what we came for, the tanker will be
sent.
and the vehicle's pilot he's the only one who underwent the
VR training no one else can do it are you sure you can trust
him your part in the mission is complete you are to leave at
once no it's not over yet not yet I have a bad feeling about
this mission you're sure this to me that you would leave the
unit once the mission was complete do not worry this is a
country of liberty no this This is where I belong, with the
unit.
I have nowhere else to go.
Look how he's just like, just become American, man.
I want to stay and fight.
Father.
There is no choice to make here, Olga.
Olga.
Need I remind you that you are carrying my grandchild?
Pregnant.
You will be on the helicopter out of here now.
Wee.
I guess she's like, get out of here.
Just get out of here.
Or she's doing the most awkward wave you've ever seen.
Yeah!
Hands over your head now!
I've seen a live dubbing of this scene before.
Freeze.
A woman.
Show your face.
You men.
You're all the same.
Who are you?
Oh, guys, that was him!
We have nomads.
wanderers I said to move Americans so you should women too
I'm a nomad too what else do you have there take the knife
and toss it the pits
not there it actually I feel like it suits her like it looks
good she just looks so good hold that position now turn
around you know what you're doing she's just so awesome
she's tough i know i love that whoa it stopped me not too
shabby is it new york i mean
How do you reload that?
I guess there's some way to.
Oh.
Ah!
And that brings our duel to its conclusion.
Scout knife with a surprise.
You are Spetsnaz.
You are Spetsnaz!
I think you deserve a little credit.
No one's ever dodged that shot of mine.
But no one gets lucky twice either.
Yeah, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna get hit.
It's okay.
She didn't expect to like you know oh oh gosh okay she
didn't okay i have to remember how to do this again oh let's
see i know that i got it i've been with the unit since i was
born i grew up on the battlefield conflict and victory were
my parents you just talked to your dad the unit is my life
my family i don't want to hear it we've shared everything on
the bad and all the good i don't want to hear Nothing else
matters to me.
We both got each other?
You're non-stopping us.
Oh, it showed me the light.
It was just like, hey, buddy, you might want to, like, you
know, do that.
Oh, shoot.
Ah!
Where are you going?
Can I get it now?
Or...
I'm actually not even sure.
Did she throw?
Oh, God, did you throw that?
Oh, I need you to be honest with me, okay?
Can I get her from there?
Oh,
I got her too somehow.
Oh, that was
close.
She did a little dance.
It's okay, I can get it too.
Uh, can I actually?
Uh, where do I get it from?
Yeah, you thought you thought you could.
You thought you were so slick.
Hey, Olga, you thought.
Did she come over here?
Can I even reach her?
Ah!
Now
you're just showing off.
You're literally just showing
off.
Okay, you're all back on this side.
I got her.
Okay, get the shot.
Do a flip!
Where is she?
She'll pop up.
Oh, there she is.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Where'd she go?
Oh, she's over there.
We're being rude.
We'll just hold on to this for now.
Good aim, Minto.
Stop being sarcastic.
Don't, I don't need your sass.
I don't need your sass.
Please.
Please!
This is a mess.
Lay down, Snake.
Take a breather, buddy.
That was my fault.
My timing was completely off.
It's okay.
My timing was just off.
Completely.
Don't do it.
But, you know, something, something, fool me once.
Oh, shoot.
You zigged when you should have zagged.
I know.
I'm distracted by armpits.
It's true.
I'm like, walkie, walkie, walkie, walkie, walkie, walkie,
walkie, walkie, walkie, walkie.
I sure was a fight.
Your child will be fine.
Probably.
Oh, God!
We killed her!
I thought this was...
Don't eat too many tranquilizers, you guys.
We gotta know...
Her child was not fine.
Her child's fine.
Oh!
Cypher.
It looks like R2D2.
And, like, a little floaty.
Cypher?
Otakon, the ship appears to be under their control.
The men have Russian gear, but I haven't been able to find
out anything else about their origin.
I know who they are.
You do?
We've ID'd the old man.
Why does Otakon sound so late?
Sergei Gurlukovic.
Oh, Gurlukovic.
One of Ocelot's allies.
Yeah, the Gru Colonel.
He's the one Ocelot was supposed to meet up with after
Shadow Moses.
Yeah!
They're after Metal Gear.
Everything's changed.
This is not gonna be as simple as we thought I believe so
you could say that I saw a surveillance remote just now.
It looked like the cipher a Marine cipher right now army
Army then the Russians now the army you're right.
This isn't gonna be simple Snake there's something I have to
tell you.
What?
We didn't dig up this info about the new metal gear on our
own Not like usual.
Argon.
Why are you keeping secrets from me?
it was a tip an anonymous anonymous you've never trusted
those why would you start now I I have a younger sister a
step sister we have different parents step bro I only knew
her for two years you've never mentioned her before so the
sender of the tip was EE EE her name is Emma but I always
call her EE why would you Emma yeah it just caught my eye
you know such a bad it was a coincidence but couldn't get it
out of my mind it's easier to say emma than ee when was the
last time you saw her over 10 years ago you think it's a
trap dolores out here i don't know after i got the tip i did
break into the pentagon system to get confirmation okay
watch your back snake maybe i screwed up i've got a light
equipped usp i can take them on now there's no ammo but it
takes a nine millimeter just like the marines m9 i'll find
those somewhere around here don't raise too much it with
that thing okay i hear you i won't kill yet actually i love
having a tranquilizer truly i think it makes things so much
easier what do you got for me can i get her a dog tag oh yay
i wish i could take this but i'm just too good at the game
Take a picture of her?
Say cheese!
Did he just kiss the...
This guy?
His libido?
His vibrato?
His everything.
Snake?
David?
Snake.
Solid David Snake.
is up with?
What is wrong with you?
I like going to the very tippy top.
What a thrill.
It's the wrong game, but I'm singing it anyway.
I gotta go to the bathroom, you guys.
Is it okay if I go to the bathroom, I'll put... I'm just
gonna chill up here.
I'll be right back.
You guys can have some Rain ASMR.
Will I go to the bathroom?
Three?
Four?
I'm back!
Wow!
I got myself a little snack too.
A little... Did you enjoy the ASMR?
Did you enjoy that?
All that ASMR goodness.
Oh, I'm supposed to say, oh, I'm supposed to say, oh, I need
to you.
I'm the mate.
Oka-doka.
I always, I never learned my lesson, you guys.
I always say, don't drink coffee, because it makes me too...
Why don't I get off of here?
And it makes me too shaky, it makes me too hungry.
But I'm like, I gotta stay awake for these three.
The rain honks you honks you me me me me me I do it every
time isn't there a guy over here
or am I crazy oh my god I can't even see the sight I got it
anyway
The picture of Olga looks like she's like because it's so
pixelated it looks like she's dead It just looks like she's
dead.
Isn't caffeine bad for your lovely voice though?
I don't know.
I think probably, but I don't drink that much coffee.
I only drink it when I'm like...
I didn't sleep well last night, so...
She isn't?
Oh!
Oh, there he is.
I was like, I know some guy comes out here.
Hey.
I'm shooting too slow.
I'm too slow!
I'm getting
his steps in.
Some more bullets.
All the bullets that I wasted trying to get this guy.
This keeps looking like a locker to me.
You're not just pretty good.
You're really good.
Snake's tiny step is when he...
You guys see that?
He's like...
I messed it up.
That's fine.
Go!
Snake!
I have a wet box.
Oh, rolling down some stairs.
How do I... it's X, right?
out of curiosity are you able to do this or any other future
mgs runs with snake in a tux
maybe i would have to beat it first though right calling out
calling about olga has oticon and snake mentioned marrow oh
this is the bridge oh but it's not just a place where you
steer the ship in a modern tanker navigational engine
control communication and all other major operational
functions are consolidated in the bridge the ship is
autopiloted via a global positioning satellite system this
is a precision instrument we're talking about here so it's
probably best to leave it alone no I'm gonna make a crash
into a bridge or something I don't know the Hudson River
bridge hey snake you found a handgun it's a decent one USP
the USP fires real bullets not the knockout rounds the m9
uses you know that right yeah the usp isn't equipped with a
suppressor either if you fire it when their enemies nearby
they'll probably hear you keep that in mind i know having
the usp will make combat easier but being undetected is
still the best way to go okay okay
snake metal gear is in the holds below the tanker's deck go
down down okay wait if i go back outside where Olga is?
Will he mention her?
Just noticed the stream.
Kept awaiting, huh?
Welcome!
Is it a bad time to tell you that box is slaying for
something?
People said that before!
Oh, she's up here.
Oh, she's gone!
Eaton by the birds.
Sorry, Olga.
Oh, come on.
Keep going.
Oh, well.
It's okay.
Nothing here.
I want to see what my box, my new box looks like.
Wet box.
Wet and weak.
No!
Wet and weak box.
My flimsy fragile sad wet box.
Whose footprints are these?
No!
I'm gonna call one more time, we'll see what he says.
Oh wait, he told me to go down, that's right.
This is the bridge.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh yeah, let's save.
We had more people...
Oh my god.
More people join us, so...
Time to save?
Yeah!
What in weak sounded like a good time?
Another Chinese proverb.
Let's go!
Those who look to the heavens prosper.
Those who defy it are no more.
Do you know this one?
The meaning here is...
Snake doesn't even respond.
That you can only survive as long as you're a part of part
of the natural order of things.
You remember pre-ripped jeans?
Manufacturers thought that just because people loved old,
broken-in jeans, they would want to buy new jeans that
looked old.
New jeans!
Gojumbo does it again!
When the jeans have to do with nature and order, denim
should fray and rip on its own, naturally, right?
Some designers tried to go against that and no one bought
them.
The earnings report from that fiscal year is enough of a
proof.
Earnings?
Why does it end there?
Oh my goodness.
Did they come through here?
Oh no, now he's on that side.
But we still got our little...
Oh, what if I...
Or spim.
Nah.
I forgot.
Can I shoot through the box in this one?
No.
I guess it's too OP.
so sad
flawed recessive genes all right to go downstairs i'm
just gonna put you over here mister yeah right there you got
anything for me oh yeah i guess i could shoot the the thing
to turn it uh what's it called Do they hear me though?
I don't remember.
That part, right?
I'm scared.
What if he hears me?
I'm too scared!
I'm too scared.
All right, let's go.
Oh,
what?
Oh, what?
Oh, it's this room!
I forgot about this one.
Yeah!
Fuck
me!
Isn't there stuff like underneath the table?
Time for a snack!
I wish.
What's over there anyway?
Why is there just- why is it in the most random spot?
I guess for that door?
Hmm.
Excuse me.
Snake is so considerate.
Oh dang, heart rash.
Oh yeah, we can shoot it now.
It's all right.
Hold on.
I'm going to grab this though.
And then...
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Don't wake up now, mister.
Don't wake up now.
So loud.
More...
Wait, where's this one go?
Oh, okay.
Calm down, calm down.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
When they do that, it scares the bonkers out of me.
I just want to hide immediately.
And I hate that.
I don't have the radar in here.
Well, why haven't we fixed the radar, huh?
When he's going to come all the way back.
Right?
Here he goes.
Okay, just run, Snake.
Just run.
Oh, that's right.
We can't go this way.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, we can shoot.
Nothing here.
Can I hide you in here?
This will be your hidey hole.
Thank you.
Bye-bye.
Just gonna do what I did before.
We're not gonna waste bullets.
We don't need to.
His neck.
Don't worry about it.
He'll just go to a chiropractor later.
It's fine.
cross the middle.
He doesn't mind.
Probably.
So I run up and then I go.
Do I have to I have a question?
Do I have to hold them up in first person only or can I do
it like this?
Here we go.
I learned.
Never mind.
Shake for me.
He's got his dog tag.
Shake!
Don't kill me.
Yippee!
Okay.
You got lucky Ronan.
This goes up.
I don't remember.
This way?
Now I'll aim at his crotch next time.
Yeah, I don't want to shoot him though.
Um...
Well, the other guy is up in there too.
Shake it, baby.
Because there's the other guy in the other room.
He'll see him collapse, you know.
Like that.
And then, from here, I'm just gonna lay down.
Um...
Wait, where is he?
Wait, where's your friend?
Oh.
Just kidding.
I think I go this way, right?
Because this is, um...
It's down here, I think?
Right?
Yeah?
Okay.
Give me your stuff!
Crack the glass.
Oh, can you?
This game is like crazy.
There's so many different ways to be able to get around in
this game and just play it in general.
Like, it's just...
It's actually insane.
What a laugh.
I thought it stopped raining.
What happened?
Oh, that's right.
Stinky guy, stinky.
Stinky!
Do I want to...
I don't...
Wait, I can't grab a stinky rashes anyway.
I don't think I can grab a stinky rations.
Wait,
how do I get in through here?
Bip.
Ah, nasty!
Can I have them actually?
No, I can't even eat a rations.
I'm on the wrong side.
Oh, okay.
Shoot.
It's fine.
We got to see her stinky friend.
Matara gone.
Barely friend.
More foe than friend.
If anything.
Stun grenade.
It's nice.
Uh-oh.
Wait, is this a spooky hallway?
Oh!
That silhouette!
No.
No!
I want to go on!
Snake, there should be a door into the holds in the
northwest section of the engine room.
Head west.
I know.
But that, but the, but the, but the, but the, but the, but
the this.
That's so, oh my God.
Raven?
No.
There's no way.
He, we saw him get eaten alive.
Snake, that's Shadow.
It's, it's him.
It's Moses.
Shadow Moses.
But Raven was, you know, out in Shadow Moses.
I know.
Maybe it's the last of his nine lives.
Or maybe his maker decided to give him another chance.
You're not serious, are you?
you maybe i am maybe i'm not snake either way we'll find out
soon we literally saw him get eaten by birds watch your step
okay there was nothing left of him
why did they never make this into an actual figure
i'll explain how to use the camera oh that digital camera
you have was
raven nendo in And yes, I will shoot him, don't worry.
Oh my gosh, is this a sexy lady?
Is this, is this, this is probably the sexiest lady.
Even better.
Take a picture of Snake.
It'll last longer.
Good.
Snake, there should be a door into the holes in the
northwest section of the engine room.
Good.
Head west.
Oh,
this game is so un-serious.
I love it.
I love this game so much.
I love this game is so stupid.
This game is so awesome.
I love this game.
Shoot his tiny little head.
Am I actually, I can't tell if I'm aiming at it or not.
I'm like going through it.
Yeah.
Deeply un-serious tactical espionage action.
Exactly.
I know like I've already been two hours on the tanker but
the tanker is just so fun you know it's so fun Look at him
go look at the shadow
No No everybody else is like downstairs and stuff
There's this guy oh yeah okay let's see who all can we get
from up here like you and i know there's a guy over here can
we see him oh there he is oh dang it i missed i missed him
again oh there we go there we go oh it's my controller there
we go oh my controller was trying to sabotage me
No, it's the button.
It really is.
That's why I was shaking.
Please forgive old...
Oh, old...
Oh, shit!
Oh, old controller.
Please forgive.
You know.
Just old controller things.
Can I drop from here?
Oh, he see me?
Oh, nice.
Can you see me from here?
Oh, shoot.
There we go.
No.
Okay.
Ah!
I think that takes care of everybody.
In this room.
Pull-ups?
No.
I tried!
I'm sick of pull-ups.
I'm sick of being healthy.
I'm tired of health.
I'm tired of taking care of myself.
Oh, I forgot there was a guy down there.
Oh, my gosh.
Nothing here.
You know, you'd be less tired if you were more fit.
Just a
box.
Do you see me now?
Oh, shit.
Oh, I almost missed that.
I almost missed that one.
I forgot about him.
Oh yes, this room too.
Wait, can I?
What was in here?
Nothing?
Just a box.
Repair of the entrance way to the engine room on the port
side is complete.
We'll return to position following patrol at the small room
on the port side.
Sick!
Did he leave?
Is he gone?
Wait, I hear him.
I think.
Good poster.
Hey, stop acting up with your hyperactive libidos,
everybody.
Am I good?
I can't tell.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, he's...
outside.
Does he come in?
No.
I don't think.
I don't remember.
I don't think so.
And Otacon, are you gonna call me?
There it is.
Snake, there's another set of infrared sensors in place.
If you touch that, the explosives will detonate and that
ship will be pulverized.
Oh no!
I'm not in the mood to go sleep with the fishes, but there
are too many sensors.
Looks like I'll have to find another way.
a way through huh take a close look do you see the thing
with blinking green lights right next to the explosives yes
that's the control unit for the sensors Wow destroy that and
the sensors stop functioning you can't get in close enough
to touch it here so you'll have to shoot it out but the M9's
knockout rounds won't work the USP you pick no they're gonna
hear it use that gun but I'm gonna hear it.
I'm almost out of film, you guys.
2000's camera.
Oh, actually, I am out of film.
What do I do?
You're gonna hear me.
Can't hear if they eat.
True.
Can I go through this room yet?
Oh, I can.
Oh.
I forgot this.
Delete Sergei.
Ah, I'm...
Okay, okay.
It's a shortcut.
Oh, I...
I didn't even realize.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna save this.
I don't think...
Saving in these games are always weird.
Oh, you need to save?
Just a second.
You really just save?
You really only save to, like...
Because if I die, I just start back at the room, you know?
You really only save for when you're done playing the game.
But it is also good to save just in case something happens.
Hey, Snake, what's hardest one most easily lost?
It's time.
Amazing how relevant these Chinese proverbs still are.
Once the moment's gone, it's gone.
Except for daylight savings time, of course.
I wish that part was dated.
Gotta love it.
Then again, you lose an hour every spring, so I guess the
proverbs are right.
I wish that part was dated.
They thought of everything.
they even have daylight savings back then of course not they
knew how to save time we're the ones that need to be tricked
into it but you said the moment never returns snake let's
not waste it on idle questions oh my god okay okay snake
doesn't even snake doesn't even argue with the guy he
doesn't even argue with him man oh my god are you kidding me
are you kidding me right now i just i missed my chance,
Otakon!
The Chinese proverbs!
Otakon.
No!
He's going even further away!
Otakon, I missed my chance.
Otakon.
Otakon is my chance coming back!
Otakon, please!
He's not gonna see me, is he?
Oh my god, I'm so scared.
Okay.
So I
Can I shoot the green things?
Wait.
Oh, the green...
Like, uh...
Oh, uh, can you shut that, please?
Thank you.
This one?
Here?
There we go.
Okay.
And...
There's more, though.
Um, I think I need to get up here, though, don't I?
For one part?
There it is.
And
the camera.
Do I zoom in again?
Zoom with O.
Okay.
Thermal goggles?
No, right?
I need to...
Actually, I think...
Let me...
Let me get down from here.
I'm zo...
Ah!
What did I overwrite?
No!
We're at the man boobs!
So sad.
Where is it?
Well, maybe I can go in closer.
Green, green, green.
And is anybody seeing green around here?
Anybody?
Anybody seeing green?
Little green light?
Am I blind?
Is that it right there?
You have to crouch?
I do?
Is that...
Green bottom right.
Wait!
No, not me!
Bottom left.
Is that it?
I wish I could scoot over a little bit more.
What if I get down on the ground?
Ah!
Oh.
Why did you do the thing that I told you to do?
This is such a good tutorial.
It really just teaches you everything.
The controls, the true boss fight.
Here's the scary part!
You are ordered to continue manning your posts until that
time.
Here's the scary part!
This hallway freaks me out, man.
A person!
Ah!
Smelly.
Stinky.
This isn't the one where I fight, right?
Oh my god.
Oh
my god.
My eyes!
Oh, I lived!
Oh,
my eyes!
Good night, sweet prince.
Is this the guy that's...
Yeah, he's jamming.
Wish I could take his tunes, though.
Oh,
I didn't mean to pick you up.
Sure, I'll carry you around.
A shame to shoot him.
I have to, I have to, just like with this buddy.
Nothing is.
I think he's the only...
Oh, dang.
other guy, right?
Excuse me.
He's listening to in the club.
Go shorty.
It's your birthday.
We're gonna party like it's your birthday.
Sippin' on my party like it's your birthday.
We don't get enough that it's not your birthday.
This is where I fight.
I don't want to fight.
I'm a pacifist now.
Okay, everybody shield your eyes.
Oh, gosh, my eyes.
My eyes.
When do we fight?
I know it's scripted.
Oh, there.
That's where we fight!
I remember these boxes!
I'll never not remember these boxes.
I'm gonna have to just ush spit.
I'm gonna ush spit everybody, I think.
Save.
Oh, I forgot.
It's okay.
Like I said, if you die, you just start back up in the same
room.
No biggie.
I'll just click continue.
Do you guys prefer Like, you know how There's the new Figma
coming out of Snake?
Do you prefer His uniform a little more blue or a little
More gray?
Because in this lighting It's really gray, but outside it's
really blue I like it Bluer, I think, but Oh my god, there's
so many guys Gray, blue The chat Is split Oh It's the dress
all over you.
The lift is also under our control.
Sir, the Marine Commander has started his speech already.
We will complete the preparations before the end of the
speech.
All communications to the halls have been severed.
No one is aware of our presence.
I'm aware.
Let no one down into the halls.
Oh gosh.
Are they gonna see me if I run out?
Secure your exit.
I'm too scared!
There is one more thing.
Yes, Columbo?
Yes, sir.
Oh, yes, sir.
She's scared.
Okay.
I'm going to put on the thermal goggles warning you guys.
Warning you now.
Oh, my God, snake.
Actually, I know what I'm going to do.
Wait.
Who goes there?
I have a question.
Um...
Is this one of those...
I had to defeat so many guys?
Or is this I just run past?
I can't remember.
Ah!
Oh, me too.
Oh, gosh.
Ah!
Is that gonna hit me?
No.
Okay.
Oh, I should also probably have my ration on just in case.
Oh my god.
Aim doko.
Aim doko!
Oh my god.
No snake, please.
No snake.
Oh my god, please!
Oh my god.
Okay, I have to really hold down the button.
I gotta...
I gotta really hold down the...
The R2.
There's one more guy, isn't there?
Oh, there he is.
There's two of us!
Three more!
Oh, I think I got him.
We're good.
The pressure controls can be wonky.
Yeah, I really am having to, like, hold it down, or else
I'm, like, wobbling all over the place.
Nice!
I only got hit once.
Yay!
Rip non-lethal run.
It's okay.
We weren't aiming for that anyway.
I enjoy all the killing.
I'm just like what Liquid said.
That's just me.
Okay, nobody knows I'm here.
Wait, whose shadow was that behind me?
They know I'm here.
They're just letting me on in.
Oh my god, he's locking me in!
Why did you try attacking me anyway?
Who goes there?
I know those boots anywhere.
They were made for walking.
And those hands were made for spinning.
Shalashaska.
Shalashaska!
Why are you here?
We thought you were with the colonel.
That's your own man!
Hosselot!
Why would you do that?
Don't tell me you're double crossing, though.
Yeah, using his one hand.
I remember cutting off the other one.
Colonel will be joining you soon.
Comrade.
Oh my gosh, I love Cherino.
Farming XP.
Comrade.
Snake, are you in yet?
Have you made it to the hold?
How do I get the libido?
How would I get the libido codec?
I'm so sad.
They may be planning to change course.
What?
The exits to the deck are all sealed.
What are they planning?
if they get metal gear we're going right off the fringe I
love this part it's so funny are you accusing my man Ocelot
of double crossing no they have no way of knowing that the
ship's been taken over I'm not interested in fighting these
guys the weapons won't do me much good here can you see
metal gear no go around to the bow they have some serious I
tried, but he never said it.
He always just said, what are you doing, Snake?
You don't have time for those.
Hmm.
Okay, Snake.
Let's go over this one more time.
Use this camera to get photographic evidence of the Metal
Gear prototype.
Now do your thing and take pictures that speak louder than
the government's plausible denials.
We need four shots.
Metal Gear from the front, front right, and front left,
close-up of the Marine Corps marking marking marking there
should be a Marines insignia on the body of metal gear yes
just let someone try explaining away a clear shot of that
right oh I see it on his little leggy all right there's
actually one little thing just spit it out I'm used to
things going wrong it looks like someone's monitoring our
transmission who I don't have a clue all they're doing is
watching it would oh these lawyers could it have something
to do with that cipher we saw yeah maybe I've switched the
encryption protocol for our burst transmission for now what
I want to do is use a different method for sending these
photos just in case okay instead of using the codec exactly
there's a workstation in the southeast corner of the block
where middle we're hacking I've made arrangements so that
you can send the pictures from the What?
Hmm?
I hitched a ride on Link 16 at the US military's proprietary
network.
Managed to get into that workstation and overwrote a part of
the system software so I could remote install a little app I
wrote.
Shut up, nerd!
Why bother with anything that complicated?
No, it's pretty simple, really.
Look, all you have to do is stand in front of the machine
and push the action button.
Okay.
The app will automatically launch and download the image
data from the camera.
Split the files and encrypt them.
faster the data packets can then masquerade as okay okay so
all i have to do is push the action button in front of the
computer once i have the pictures right yep sure if you put
it that way and one more thing the commandant's already
begun his speech but you need to get the pictures before
he's done talking otherwise they'll spot you okay the time
limit i hacked into his personal files and took a look at
the text of that speech what i'd say you have seven more
minutes if he throws in a joke or two a seven minute time
limit huh remember snake just the photos okay uh-huh these
kinds of odds i won't be making any sudden moves what but
that doesn't mean we can just let metal gear be hijacked
okay okay but first the photos all right we'll deal with the
rest when we get there right stay low okay i forgot about
the time limit i'll be honest i like this part It's so fun.
It's so fun.
The only thing that can stand up to a Metal Gear is of
course another Metal Gear.
La la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la.
With Raid, the hundreds if not thousands of Metal Gear's
that exist all in the world are no longer a threat.
La la la la la la la la la la.
And it will be the Marine Corps and our Ray that will
accomplish this.
Every industrialized nation on the globe knows the
specifications for Metal Gear.
Worse yet, so do a number of rogue states.
Um, trying to remember how to do this part.
Can I take that guy out?
Oh.
They don't notice, right?
Oh, hello?
Oh, he's so cool!
How does he do it?
What do I, what happens if I, um, wait.
How do I mess with this again?
It is a fact that players in favor of such a policy are
attempting to derail our own raid project.
But I promise you that they will make shadow puppets.
This weapon will render all other Metal Gear's obsolete.
I wonder if I can get that guy too.
Emanuel!
Thank you so much for the 20!
The light of a military dominance spelled out by Ray.
Oh.
This guy is not nearly as cool.
Alright.
That guy kind of sucks.
Nobody noticed me.
How do I make the naked ladies go on the screen?
Some say that the strategic importance of aircraft carriers
will be reduced by the completion of Ray.
The opposition from the Navy is an undeniable...
There is a lot of pressure from Navy Brass, especially those
with submarine and air background.
We'll go through this way.
Oh, the next room.
But this project is vital to the Marine Corps.
The enemy is sometimes closer to home than you think,
gentlemen.
There we go.
No, no, no, Snake, please.
Lay down.
Oh, I guess we're going backwards.
Okay, there we go.
Wow, this looks so familiar, doesn't it?
I feel like you don't really go through vents in this game,
except in this part.
I have a daughter.
I know that,
unlike the army's wrecks, it can prove deep underwater.
Move in undetected and make its landing on any shoreline.
Okay.
It's on-door joint-touchable information
airing accuracy and takes them out with massive firepower.
It is the ultimate weapon, and it is yours to guard.
I'd like you all to think about what that means.
Okay.
We made it.
The National Missile Defense Program initiated in the...
Nice.
We made it.
I only have four minutes left.
The National Missile Defense Program was initiated in the
end of the 20th century.
Projected to completion in 2005.
However, the NMD that was conducted in the year 2000 was a
complete failure.
Oh.
And the success of the 1999 trials is now considered a
chance happening.
Ladies.
Most boring movie ever.
Oh.
Ah!
would mean a new world order.
We, the Marine Corps, will play a central role in its
military affairs.
Ooh, la la!
I love gravure!
Blah!
Snake.
Snake just can't help himself.
I can't even move.
Paying attention to what matters.
I'm saving them.
Wow!
Yeah!
Which do we look at?
Aw.
No!
What's going on?
Snake!
Change it back!
Anyway, that was a good time.
Um...
Projected to completion in 2005.
Oh.
However, the NMD trial conducted in the year 2000 was a
complete failure.
Oh my gosh, this scared me.
The success of the 1999 trials is now considered a chance
happening.
I think I might just want to run.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
I forgot that they could hear me.
Oh my gosh, this scared me.
so much I even saw the the metal on the ground I was just
like hmm I forgot that this is a cutscene
minigun minigun I've been playing this game for 20 years and
I had no idea you could do that with the projector I feel
like every time I play this game someone is always just like
wait you can do that wait you can do that every time Snake!
The National Missile Defense Program was initiated in the
end of the 20th century.
Projected to completion in 2005.
However, the NMD trial conducted in the year 2000 of
complete failure.
The success of the 1999 trials is now preceded a chance
happening.
Oh my god.
Hey, get back in position!
Get back in position, soldier.
What are you doing?
We have intelligence that there are anti-Metal Gear
terrorists Did they go back?
Oh my god, I hate when they do this.
Intruder to the right!
Ah!
Oh my god.
Intruder to the left!
Yeah!
At ease, okay.
Should that actually happen, I expect you to be prepared.
We cannot and will not give up Ray.
Stay on your guard at all times.
I'm on my guard.
Okay.
There was no technological solution in sight.
Ah!
Intruder to the left.
Intruder to the right.
Here it is.
Snake looks so good.
The current state of the Imperial Reformation is important.
Direct yourself, a better bet.
Metal Gear.
A trigger to the left.
Wow!
Grab your reload.
Metal Gear!
Ray is so pretty.
Zom!
There was no technological solution in sight, and the
program was already attracting strong hold on i gotta send
my sexy ladies to autocon first i can't believe i rode over
the man boom though so sad
people pop bb kernel bb incorrect scott incorrect scott One,
two, three, four, five, six, seven.
Scott.
So green.
I'm hacking.
This is on me.
Sprite?
Sensibility programs.
It's so cool.
Photo viewer.
There he is.
So, any codec moments from you, Snake?
Yes.
The first one I'm seeing is...
Is.
Ah, this is...
What?
It's nothing.
But this isn't a photo of Metal Gear anyway.
Sorry, but you're gonna have to go back and shoot another
set.
I'll just make a backup of this one.
Zah!
Uba!
Arakan, your dog!
Okay, what am I seeing now?
More of these?
Is that all you think about?
Hey, what you like is your business.
Just get those Metal Gear pictures!
I'll just make a backup of this one.
Oh, look at that!
The next ones...
Oh.
Hmm.
Isn't this that soldier on the deck, Olga?
Yes.
I can't believe you took a picture of her.
All things considered.
Why not?
What's next?
You're not gonna make a backup for that one though?
Oh.
I'm sorry.
You need to take another one.
No!
The next image is...
He doesn't like...
Oh.
I don't think we can use this.
Oh, my bad picture.
The last one is...
sexy picture okay didn't think girlukovic was involved we
need four images okay one from the front right front front
left and then the marines front right front left the
prototype front right front left the prototype on camera
okay disconnect okay um can i take this guy out oh Hello?
Oh, okay.
Um...
So...
Does this count?
Yay!
Good.
...succeeded in deploying the program.
Some say that it was a military interest, with plans for the
$100 billion program budget that actually arranged the
legislative approval.
Ah!
Oh my god, he scared me so bad.
I just thought I would sneak behind him, you know?
Okay, I get it.
I don't need all the dramatics.
Oh, Snake, the walk of shame.
Bro, I'm up so fast.
I know, right?
It's okay.
Get him.
Do I have to do this part again?
I think so.
Yeah.
I'm just going to skip through it.
Well, if I could.
I don't know if I...
Okay, first up.
Oh!
I kept that.
Neat!
Russia and China for its potential the violation of the
anti-ballistic missile agreement.
The fact that any development in missile defense would
trigger accelerated weapons development has been pointed out
from the very beginning.
Don't look this way.
That guy is on another floor.
Okay.
How do I get over?
I don't remember how to get over there, to be honest.
Um, can I go behind?
guy out to him former president sears did also act towards
reducing the nuclear stockpile while nurturing the nmd
content it was he who lowered start three ceiling for
tactical nuclear weapons in order to bring russia marines
everyone believed the world was headed for the end of the
arms marines is it on the other side you're not so proud
that you put it all over the place okay It's fine, I guess.
Further back?
Ah!
Kachai!
Good.
When did they move?
I can't remember.
What if I take him out?
That'd be so funny.
...
Hunk me!
Hunk me me me me me me me me Make that contingency likely
But if this theory is correct It means that there was a
calculated intent To cash in on this opportunity Scary Scary
We are here today To flush out and rid our country of these
corrupting forces That is our mission You will bear that in
mind Oh my god Oh my god.
Oh my god.
George Sears?
The official reason given did not of course include the
development of Metal Gear Rex and next generation nuclear
warheads.
I don't think they could see me.
Oh my god.
Where am I?
This guy.
Some say that the strategic importance of aircraft carriers.
George Sears.
Okay.
I guess I need to go here.
There is a lot of pressure from Navy grads.
What counts as...
Especially those with submarine and air background.
What counts as front...
Oh my gosh, I don't have much time left.
Is he gonna start talking about his daughter?
Yippee!
Okay.
I seem to be repeating myself.
Chalk it up to old age.
Um...
Front left and front.
Okay.
Uh...
Do you think maybe...
Should it be a wet box or a box?
This Metal Gear Ray is a prototype.
Designed to be operated by an onboard pilot.
Nobody will see me.
Right here.
Ray will be unmanned.
Driven by tele-existence.
How does he not notice that?
The Marines label?
Oh, I already got it.
You must be tense!
Yeah, just a little.
Just in time, baby.
Only one alert.
One on purpose.
Looks like I have your photos now.
Let's take a look.
Okay.
one I'm seeing is is you're a pretty good photographer we
can definitely use this left shot nice wait what's next it
used all wait I didn't overlap any of them works wait it's a
great front view the last one is wait this is great the
Marines lettering shows up really well yippee okay now we
have all the photos yeah snake the speech is about to wind
up Forget the photos and get out of there now.
I'm on my way.
You're not going to show them the pretty ladies?
I already did.
He made backups of them even.
We'll lead the charge into a new world order with Metal Gear
Ring.
Snake, what are you doing?
Just stand in there.
That is all.
Dismissed.
Oh, gosh.
They're going to notice me.
Slow clap.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Salute.
Who's making that racket?
Excellent speech, my friend.
Who the hell?
Gift of the silver tongue.
They say it's the mark of a good officer.
How is he clapping?
End of a liar.
Americans are too in love with the sound of their own voice
to speak the truth.
He has only one hand!
I'm jealous.
I am Shalashasca.
Also called Revolver.
Ocelos.
Yeah!
That guy!
I love that guy.
I know that guy.
I love him.
So quiet.
So tense.
What do you want?
This machine will be quite useful.
What are you planning to do?
I love this man like you wouldn't believe.
No, I'm taking it back.
Dead mom.
Snake.
Snake, keep listening.
Oh.
He's just standing.
Oh my god.
Blow his hat off.
that sneaky guy nobody move understood
oh my god they're still filming um hello we're just making
everybody panic
i have a walkie-ducky this ship now carries enough syntax on
its key i have a bomb
Don't do it.
That's right.
We're going to drown.
No one has to die needlessly.
I have a hand.
Let me give you a hand.
Oh my god!
There are the good Luke of H.
Seligers.
We're almost at the target.
Get a move on.
They're working on it.
Weep, weep, weep, weep, weep, weep.
Revolver, I have a walkie-talkie also.
My ears, oh my god, please.
Could we do without the realistic sound effects here?
What do you intend to do with Wayne?
Sell it on the streets?
I was raised in Snezinsk, formerly known as Chelyabinsk 70,
the nuclear research outpost.
Research outpost.
What are you talking about?
I didn't ask for your life's story Is there a point to this
sad story?
Oh friends dignity all sold to the highest bidder the United
States of America Even the technology that gave birth to
these weapons is Russian developed by us by us what do you
intend to do?
Russia will rise again.
Oh The brain is the key I read to inform you that I have no
idea intention of selling metal gear as i said i came to
take it back oh wait ocelot you couldn't be you couldn't be
double crossing them could you no you wouldn't do that yes
oh yes
surely not yes i was never This home was brought out by the
Americans.
Sorry for the spoilers.
No hard feelings, Colonel.
Mother Russia can rot for all I care.
No!
Since when, Ocelot, when did you turn?
I'm glad you noticed, Comrade.
Comrade.
I abandoned her during the Cold War.
Metal Gear only has room for one.
What's going on?
You and your daughter will die here.
No!
Damn you!
Can you say...
Why do you want me to say Lollililil?
Not meant to!
Mint, can you say Lollililil for me?
Why do you guys keep asking me to say Lollililil?
He's too good.
Looks like you were Gosh, Ocelot, he's pretty good.
Oh.
Imagine your final word being treacherous dog.
Treacherous dog!
Ocelot's so cool!
Look at him go!
Yeah!
Dariririr.
He's pretty good.
I love this old man.
Show's over.
If you wish to live, I suggest you run now.
Uh-uh.
This ship is still in the lower New York harbor.
You may yet make it to shore and you swim for your life.
Ah!
You blew it up anymore!
I'm rocking.
Stormtrooper aim!
Ocelot!
Yeah, Teen Titans Robin, would that help?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, it's switched.
His hand.
He's got it back.
Oh!
No way!
It's been a while, brother.
Who are you?
You know who I am.
Like what?
Like when?
Not so young anymore, eh, snake?
Eh, snake!
You're drowning in time.
I know what it's like, brother.
No wonder Naomi passed you over for the fox dive program.
I don't think she did.
Is he like, gnawing on his arm?
He's literally, like, biting liquid.
The price of physical prodigy.
A few more years and you'll be another dead clone of the old
man.
Our raw materials are vintage, brother.
His boss was in his late 50s when they created his copies.
Oh.
But I, I live on through this arm.
Oh my god.
Oh my god's arm.
Ah!
This part is so whack.
I love it.
Oh no.
Well, I say oh no.
I don't care about this guy.
I care about Olga, though.
That guy, he's dead too.
This part is so Titanic-coated.
Ah!
I
don't know which one of your arms is possessed.
All of me is possessed, baby!
Oh my gosh.
I can't wait.
You guys, Ray does the cutest thing here.
Ray does the cutest thing!
Cinema.
His roar?
Even cuter!
Ray does the cutest thing!
You don't have what it takes off the roll!
Oh my gosh, imagine.
Suddenly you have to fight Ray.
With your usp.
You're going down, Snake!
With this tanker!
Wah!
Oh my god, Snake!
Don't die on the tanker, please.
Snake, no!
The music?
Oh, silly guys.
He's like, hey, hey, stop shooting him.
I'm gonna shoot him instead.
Hey, stop shooting him.
Why don't we have any countermeasures for this thing?
Look how cute he is!
His eyes are really spread apart.
Yeah!
Oh, God.
Don't trip.
When's he gonna do the thing?
I love Ray's noises, too.
Snake, wake up, please!
You're making me nervous.
You're making me nervous, Snake.
Please, wake up.
Get up, Snake.
angle i think so
oh my god here he goes yes go go go do your little sippies
look how cute he is he's sipping up he's taking a big old
sip yeah
What are you going to do with that sip?
You know, water, laser.
He's so thirsty!
I love Ray!
Snake!
Oh my god, Snake, please wake up.
Snake.
Snake!
The cliffhanger.
There we go.
Little Ray Swimming out with his tail I love this part too
Look how cute he is
He's so awesome Oh, thank goodness Snake, you're scaring me
Power Wash Simulator DLC Where you play is right
Let's do it, do it, do it, do it, do it, do it, do it, do
it, do it, do it, do it Proceeding F plan, sir I saw this
boat in half.
Backflip!
Doop!
I love Ray.
Ray is so awesome.
He's so nimble.
He's so special.
He's so great.
Look at him swim!
Yes, sir.
I have photographic evidence of snake on the scene.
The cipher was most useful.
Yes, sir.
I look forward to tomorrow morning's news flash I would say
the Marine Corps plans are on indefinitely.
Oh, yes, of course, Mr. President.
Oh my god.
Goodbye tanker
What if snake didn't know how to swim?
Oh my gosh, it's only been three hours.
That is so, like, for the course, I feel.
I feel like it's so easy to spend so much time on just the
tanker.
Can't believe Ocelot was possessed by Anthony from Eternal
Darkness.
What a twist.
Oh, man.
Hey, we beat Metal Gear Solid 2.
scientists had to make thousands of calculations to create
the atomic bomb and determine its effects.
Computers and atomic bombs, both products of World War II,
grow up together.
Smithsonian Institute.
Quickest three hours.
I've always assumed...
Snake, do you remember the sinking of that tanker two years
ago?
The arm thing is just another oscillot double triple cross.
A hole in an oil tanker full of crude, barely 20 miles off
the shore of Manhattan.
No, he's possessed by liquid.
Your classic nightmare.
It didn't take long for the government to put an oil around
the whole mess and then that massive offshore cleanup
facility went up inside the big shell I hear the cleanup
isn't quite over yet it takes time but in the meantime the
shells become a landmark a symbol of environmental
protection snake sounds more twiki approximately six hours
ago the big shell was seized by an armed group do we have an
id former members of the navy seal special anti-terrorist
training squad dead cell red cell yeah it's a highly trained
group i love dead cell i hope they I hope they yell good so!
Ah!
Wow, big shell.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
What a freak.
Offshore decontainment facility, big shell.
Now for your top priority is to rescue and safeguard the
president.
Team Bravo, watch out for Stilman's back and get the OC4 in
this arm.
I'm so excited
What are their demands 30 billion dollars 30 billion dollars
what makes them think they can get that gosh They have
really upgraded from the one million dollars or one billion
dollars a VIP from one of the major Big shell dead cell and
one from a government the most important person in sense the
most important person James Johnson James Johnson the
president.
Unless the demands are met, the terrorists intend to blow
the big shell out of the water.
And the crude will ignite, turning the Manhattan Harbor into
an inferno.
That's not the worst case scenario.
If the chloride's being used to decontaminate the sea water,
go up with the oil.
Toxins containing catastrophic levels of dioxins will be
released.
In other words, the bay's ecosystem will be wiped out.
And the sea will turn into a toxic soup for centuries,
becoming the worst environmental disaster in history.
Soup.
Spicy soup.
Can't unhear the voice of Chuni VTuber.
I've watched before in the past when I played Swash's game.
One, infiltrate the offshore decontamination facility Big
Shell and safeguard their president and other hostages.
And two, disarm the terrorists by any means necessary.
If they have a voice like Raiden.
You should know that Seal Team 10 is also conducting a
rescue operation.
The butt is acceptable.
Is this a joint effort?
It's just not the same.
Foxhound remains a covert body.
Oh my god, there's bugs everywhere.
That is an order.
Okay.
I got this.
Stealth.
Oh my gosh, here it comes.
Yes.
This is Snake.
I'm now inside Strut A of Shell 1.
How are things?
I don't know.
Looks like there are no sentries posted here.
Why does he talk like this?
Why does Snake have white hair?
Because, you know, he like got so shocked by the tanker,
turned his hair white.
Brand new hole cut through the oil fence.
Brand new hole.
There's someone else besides me that wanted to get in badly.
That's not possible.
That's right.
They landed on the roof of the big shell as planned.
And by the way, Snake, we're changing your code name for all
following communication.
What's wrong with Snake?
Just a precaution.
caution designated riden riden you've already covered
infiltration in vr training huh i've completed 300 missions
in vr i feel like some kind of legendary mercenary okay
we'll skip that part make sure nobody okay riden don't get
ahead of yourself contact me by codec the frequency is
140.85
I feel like a legend.
All right, Ryden.
What are you talking about?
When you hear that noise, press the select button.
Thank you.
The codex receiver directly stimulates the small bones of
your ear.
It's Axel from Kingdom Hearts.
Be still my heart.
First, make your way to the upper section of the big shell.
How do I get up to the next level?
Oh.
There's an elevator at the far end of that.
area use that okay sounds good sounds good your new sneaking
suit uses electro fiber technology a byproduct of fiber
optics research the texture isn't far removed from rubber
but the material protects against a wide range of toxic oh
my gosh turn around for us girl to a smart skin and military
R&D data about The mask is so scary.
Woo!
This exchange between the suit and the intravenous
nanomachines to create a feedback system.
I was trained by a video game.
Relax, the suit applies varying pressure to major internal
organs to maximize performance and shape-guided functions.
Colonel, there's so much pressure on my torso, it's really
snatching my waist.
It's making my waist really tiny and grabbable.
The hatch with a circular handle will open into the elevator
area.
Locate the hatch first.
Copy that.
Moving on to main mission objectives.
Yippee!
Yeah!
Right!
Why, everybody, welcome to Eww!
Welcome to Bug Smush Simulator.
Nasty, nasty.
Eww!
Woohoo!
Ew, ew, ew, ew, ew, ew.
Welcome to the start
of Metal Gear Solid 2, baby!
We made it!
I recognize this from a VR stream.
I know!
And we're actually here now!
We're actually here now.
So fun.
Oh, uh, where's the entrance?
There we go.
Only took us four hours.
Uh, three, thank you very much.
Oh.
Ew.
Was there anything down here?
I can't remember.
Is there anything in the water?
Go in.
Yes?
Okay, I thought so.
Alright.
How to swim.
Uh.
thank you colonel perfect timing i don't i've got your feet
wet these are the basic controls for swimming i don't feel
the water and move forward by pushing the punch button push
it in rapid succession to swim faster i don't feel like
change your heading with the left analog stick up will take
you up down takes you lower left and right to face those
directions the o2 gauge will appear under your life gauge
while you're underwater the gauge corresponds to the amount
of air you can hold from a single deep breath Once the O2
gauge falls to zero, the life gauge will start to drop.
You need to be aware of that.
Punch button.
Which one was punching?
Oh gosh.
Oh, shoot.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
Oh, swimming.
Oh, I can't go down anymore, though.
Is there actually something down here?
Maybe it's later?
Which MGS character do you like to collab with?
Ocelot.
It's there?
Am I blind?
I passed it?
I just missed it?
Oh, I see it!
I see it!
I saw it!
No, I didn't.
I thought I saw it.
I'm an idiot.
I thought I saw a ration.
I'm not even moving.
Ryden is moving all on his own.
I'm seeing the bubbles and I'm thinking it's something.
Where did I pass it?
Slightly up.
Oh,
I see it!
Sure, sure, I see it!
Get it.
Get it, Ryden.
Yes!
Okay.
I always forget that, um...
Or rather, you know how, like, in some games, when you swim,
up is actually down, down is actually up?
That's where I'm confused.
Because it's not, it's not, it's proper in this one.
Up is up and down is down.
But I'm not used to it like that.
I can't believe, I tried so hard to get the hyperactive
libido.
I'm so sad I didn't get it.
I tried so hard to get that voice, that Kodak call.
I wonder why I didn't get it.
it.
No!
Inverted is best.
I think when you like play so many inverted ones, it um, you
know, it makes it difficult.
Oh, what was that?
Oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, that's not me.
Why am I, why are you looking around so erratically?
Oh,
there's, there's people here.
The codec calls are really easy to miss in this game.
Yeah, I really wanted to see that one, though.
It's so funny.
It lives rent-free in my brain.
I can never stop thinking about...
About Snake's hyperactive libido.
A Russian private army that was in line to work with the
Shadow Moses takeover group four years ago.
What's their stake in this one?
They must have made a deal.
An arrangement with the terrorists.
They become a band of mercenaries.
Oh.
Are you with anybody else?
The elevator is at the extreme north end.
The extreme north.
Take the elevator to the upper section of the big shell.
The totally tubular north.
The radical north.
Hope there's nobody here.
Oh my god, I can't wait to take off this stupid mask.
Army with no nation?
Right in.
Be sneaky.
Oh, he took him out.
Wow, he took that ass.
I know that ass.
Anywhere.
Colonel, there's definitely another intruder in here besides
me.
Oh, and he's sexy.
Not a team.
Looks like a solo job.
One man.
We may not know who he is.
is but he managed to take care of every century in the area
they're all out cold he's crazy he is he's got some skills
we need to get an ID but for now you can take advantage of
the situation and get to work yeah there's a terminal in
front of the elevator a node did you say nerd not nerd node
oh use the node to gain access to the big shells facilities
network then what pull up the map of the That'll let you
activate the Soliton radar true that radar came in useful
during VR training A radar system uses biological magnetic
fields as input these estimated enemy positions are
projected onto a map According to reference points collected
via GPS signals and field personnel I think one of my
favorite parts is that is like The map through the big
shells node not even a localization thing.
That's just one-to-one translation The node unit is about
three feet high.
It should be colored blue.
So it's just so stupid.
Did you say mint?
Just push the action button in front of the node.
In front of the nerd.
I'm going to action the nerd.
The nanomachines in your body will take care of the security
clearance.
And allow you access to the node.
Complete the procedure before those sentries gain
consciousness.
If they spot you...
I don't know, why do I have nanomachines in my body?
I won't be able to gain access for a while.
on guard.
Okay.
Got it.
Oh my god, we get to put in our name here.
Beep, boop, boop, boop.
Ah!
Why are the nanomachines doing this?
Why?
Why is...
Oh.
My name.
I'm
a lovely lady my birthday
December October 1st my blood type question mark because I
am a ghost my nationality ghost what if I put question mark
yeah we'll just be of the USA baby the US of A the mint
Stop!
Zanzibar.
Yippee!
And we get all of our options here!
So fun!
Yeah?
Good work, Raiden.
Thank you!
The radar should be functioning now.
Yeah.
Remember your VR training sessions.
The tool is exactly the same one.
It maps the terrain as well as the position of enemy
personnel okay the bright dot in the middle is you riding i
love that you get the tutorial now and the blue cone shape
represents their field of vision your radar isn't affected
by the weather yuppie but if you're discovered by an enemy
you won't be able to use it it get you can't replay mgs is
infectious it's all made from currently existing technology
you won't be able to use it in an area with strong harmonic
resonance so be Careful.
The big shells layout map should now be available after
touching the start button.
Ah, yippee!
I've set aside proprietary frequency for saves and an
analyst to work on the data too.
Who could it be?
Jack, is everything alright?
What are you doing here?
Jack, can you hear me?
What's going on?
Jack, I'm a part of this mission.
Colonel, what the hell is going on?
Um, excuse me?
Meet the mission analyst.
She'll be overseeing the data.
saving and support why her why her that was supposed to take
part in this mission was in an accident rosemary was brought
in as a replacement an accident and according to the files
it's now in my place can wait for mgs con right now let's go
but an intelligence analyst is no field officer not to worry
she has our technical staff at her disposal she's never been
a part of a field mission this is insane i have my own
reasons for selecting her for this mission Colonel, I fail
to see...
I know your VR training performance in and out, but
sometimes that's not enough.
Yeah.
You're familiar with the Shadow Moses incident?
You know I covered it in VR.
Oh, yeah, 300 missions.
If there's a crucial tactical detail that case taught us.
What's that?
It was the power of the operatives' will to survive.
Ooh.
I was trained to fight.
My personal feelings have no place in a mission.
We've learned that it doesn't work that way.
And on the field, you need all the help you can get.
I need a lady.
Jack, you're stuck with me.
whether you like it or not rose rose to watch your back but
i have conditions that need to be met colonel oh she's a
lady with conditions i'll perform my duties and save that
mission data good but i'm aware that technically i'm not
part of the mission control team yes after all i'm just a
normal girl he's worried about her girl but that means
colonel that i am not required to follow your orders outside
of my immediate duties jack is not simply a field personnel
for me to track his comes first to me not the mission and
because of that i will be monitoring and keeping a record of
every communication you have with him colonel given the
circumstances you're free to do what you see fit hey i
prefer this to being kept in the dark waiting i'd like to
make a request if i may yes of course his handle is ridden
for the duration of the mission could you call him that Yes,
sir.
All right, Ryden.
Ryden.
Let me know when you're ready to turn in a save.
How long do you think that's going to last?
The proprietary save frequency is 140.96.
How long do you think she's going to call him Ryden for?
I just switched frequencies.
Jack?
What?
Do you know what day it is tomorrow?
April 30th.
Is there something special about it?
Oh, God.
It's already starting.
Oh, no.
I'm sorry.
I'm so excited.
I'll keep trying until I hear the answer.
I should have...
I'm going to let you go now, Jack.
I should have had a heartbeat monitor on for this game.
Maybe next time.
Oh, my God.
Ah!
They're going to wake up.
Uh-oh.
Ryden, the enemy sentry is regaining consciousness.
Be careful, Jack.
Ryden!
My name is Ryden!
You must stay out of sight.
Please, Rose, my...
You have one job.
Oh, my God.
I'm under enemy fire.
Secure the perimeter.
Secure.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
Nothing?
No one.
There's no one.
There's nothing.
No, you don't.
No way.
Already?
Please.
No additional assistance.
No additional assistance, Bozo.
Sorry.
Um, I don't know where he is.
Oh, God.
Where is he?
Ah, the elevator's here!
Just go, Ryan.
Just go.
Nothing here.
Anyway.
Yeah, I said that nobody could help him.
So sad.
Yeah!
No problems here, everybody.
It's the perfect escape.
Oh, my gosh.
It's just like...
Sons of Liberty!
The name of their leader is Solid Snake.
The hero of Shadow Moses?
So that's why you changed my code name.
Right.
But he can't be the Solid Snake.
He died two years ago on that tanker.
Snake died!
Not just because he ripped his pants.
Not a chance.
It's just like the opening of Metal Gear Solid 1.
Solid Snake, it could be.
That guy's not working for the terrorist.
There are no sentries, but it would only take one to spot me
in this light.
You never had daylight VR training after all.
How?
What a huge oversight.
What about the commandos?
And the president?
Seems he was spotted on Strut B.
Strut B.
300 video games and not one in daylight yeah shadow moses
was all at night is comprised of shells one and two each
unit consists of a central core and six struts surrounding
it so the whole thing is shaped like two hexagons connected
end on end exactly and you're on the roof of strut a shell
one at the moment so awesome big shell is so pretty Get to a
node.
Log into the network.
Got it.
What time is it?
Okay, I still have a little bit of time.
What's this?
Get up there.
Rannon.
Bandage.
We'll need those.
But, ew.
Don't poop on me.
We'll get the M9 first.
poop on me don't poop on me let's see how Rose is doing my
girlfriend what's up Jack you know I just wanted to see her
face and also save
yeah saving nice Jack do you remember what day tomorrow is
that again I'm sorry but I still don't have a clue that's
okay what is it rose talk to me yeah he's such a freak how
important important enough and we'll talk about it tomorrow
rose can't you give me a hint yeah tomorrow seems more
appropriate that's a death flag I need all the help I can
get so that I won't chicken out anyway rose that's a death
flag is that the reason you decided to be part of this
mission okay I'm gonna finish this thing by tomorrow no
matter what no matter what do everything I can to help Okay.
Rose, there's something I need you to do as an analyst.
As an analyst?
It has to do with Solid Snake.
The leader of this takeover incident is claiming that he's
Snake himself.
The legendary mercenary?
I need as much data on him as possible.
Everything they have on him after the Shadow Moses incident.
He's dead now, isn't he?
Yes.
There should be a burial record somewhere, too.
You should be able to request top-level security clearance
from the Colonel.
That should get us into the most classified material.
I'm on it.
I'll contact you as soon as I find out something.
I have no idea.
I'm Ryden.
I'm an idiot.
So they even have his records?
How is that possible?
Wait, did they recover it from the ship?
Snake is really dead?
According to the SEAL Team 10's communications, the
president was cited on Strut B.
Ryden, head for Strut B.
It's to the northwest of Strut A, your current location.
Cross the connecting bridge between Strut A and Strut B.
and b you can get to the connecting i feel like i'm in
elementary get down from the roof to the first floor from a
you go to b a b c a don't forget to log in understood a
straight a straight a straight b okay hold on i have
something very important i need to do whoa Get up, Ryden.
Look, look at that nasty poop.
Hit me.
Hit me, bird.
I dare you.
Poop on me.
Poop on me, bird.
Look up.
Disgusting.
Oh.
Hello?
Is it Rose?
Aw.
Right and look at that wire fence.
You may be able to crawl through it.
Dramatic pause.
That's literally what I was doing!
Crouch down using the crawl button.
Then push the left analog stick in the direction you want to
move.
That's what I was doing, Colonel!
Push the crawl button again to stand up.
You can use weapons even while crawling.
This is different from VR training.
So you keep that in mind.
Yeah, yeah, you can.
Thank you for reminding me, Colonel.
Oh, whoops.
I think I was thinking of crouching and shooting.
Oh, hello.
Ryden.
Seal Team 10 is in.
Yubi!
Do we really have no line of communication with the seals?
I mean, wait.
They don't know a thing about us.
You know we work in the dark, and this mission is no
exception.
Only a few people know about your presence here.
But why can't they know?
This operation is under Pentagon's direct command.
And the NSDD came from the vice.
president and the secretary of defense your mission may be
top secret but it's gone through the usual channels okay you
work on the cringe I mean fringe oh my god the music oh I'll
go check the roof I'll leave the first floor to you okay
okay bye girlukovic soldier okay show off okay you're right
enough there's the nerd
colonel i've located the node but it's under heavy
surveillance i can't get in any closer you have to distract
them try making some noise to draw their attention away
scared how flatten yourself against a wall and hit the punch
button got it got it i'm gonna flatten myself against the
wall before i do that anything in here like a oh take it oh
i need the so calm first oh uh okay
oh my god scary
what if i didn't do that what if i just ran oh my god uh
hello do it
um yes exit
what's this way
punch the nerd we need to get to oh my god i can already
hear this ciphers
R2D2 Yes colonel Watch your back That's a cipher A type of
UAV No If it spots you It will alert enemy personnel
Exercise extreme caution Why is he green To set up an
interference field Nice sensors offline for a while.
Um, Colonel where?
Do I get a gun?
You can also destroy the engine or the camera.
Some of the UAVs may be armed.
Be careful.
Okay.
Copy that.
Wait a second.
I just intercepted new intelligence on the operation being
executed by Seal Team 10.
Yeah.
Intercepted?
As I said before, they need to be kept in the dark about our
presence.
So we just listen in.
I'm patching it through.
Okay, what's going on?
This is alpha zero.
We have the president.
Oh He is safe.
What about the package?
What about his package we've secured the package easy money.
Oh?
Your retrieval is on the way.
Come on home.
Come on home Alpha zero report.
Oh no Come over the president.
Mr. President.
We're under attack Is that oh Alpha zero respond what could
it be all alpha respond?
Uh-oh.
Raiden.
The president's life is in danger.
Oh my god.
We gotta go to Strupp B now.
But this doesn't go to Strupp B.
This goes to F.
This is F.
My bad.
On our way back.
Oh my god.
I knew that was gonna happen.
Oh.
Scared the heck out of me, please.
Oh my god.
What do you mean, hmm?
Ah!
Get me out of here, please.
No, no, God.
Ride it!
It would be great.
Thanks for the five gifted.
Oh my god.
I could use...
I could use some help right now.
Could you...
I don't even have a gun!
This damn guy noticing me.
I'm just gonna restart.
Kill me, just kill me already.
Please, I thought he wasn't- Yeah, like it never even
happened.
Don't even...
Don't even worry about it.
Great start, everybody.
Great, great, great, great start.
Great start.
Don't even, don't even count it.
It doesn't even count.
it doesn't even it doesn't even count okay it doesn't even
count just don't even don't even think that this happened
okay this is the gameplay i subscribed for jack
do you need to save yeah great practice run boss thank you
yeah just a practice run yeah
Saving.
Rose, are you okay?
Yes, thank you.
It really scared me at first, but I think I've gotten used
to it.
I'll be behind you all the way, so don't worry.
I guess women really are strong.
Not quite.
It's not women that are strong.
It's me.
Just as long as I can count on you.
Actually, that's not true.
It still scares me to death.
But I'll be strong.
I'll try for you.
Good luck.
What about this guy?
Get a load of this, bozo.
I have my thermal, my sensor.
Yeah, I have a chaff grenade.
Maybe I do need to go through there.
Oh, wait.
I can't, yeah, maybe I do need to go through there, and I
don't remember.
No, no, no, sir.
No, no, I'm not making the same mistake again.
You can't, you can't.
Or do I go to the other side?
Do I go to that side over there?
I can't remember.
Rose is built differently.
She is.
It is the left side, isn't it?
Here.
A-B!
There we go.
A-B.
It's like it's not AF.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Strat F has the M9.
I need a weapon.
I need a weapon!
Why is everything OSP?
Ride and watch out.
There are sentries posted on the connecting bridge.
They will spot you if you continue on course.
recommendations use the hanging hanging hanging face any
waist high railing and push the action button to clear the
railing and hang over the side once there you can move
sideways while keeping out of enemy sight all right i'm
giving it a try don't forget the grip gauge they're really
decreasing during a hanging maneuver they're really giving
him a lot of credit look oh they're giving just like, yeah,
you got this, man.
You can hang for that long, I believe in you.
I know you can do it.
Which side should I go?
Yeah!
There's the other guy on the other side.
Where'd he go?
Is this the one with downstairs?
Did he go downstairs?
Will he spot me?
If he's downstairs and I'm hanging over.
Time for level 2 grip.
Oh my god, there he is.
Yeah!
I wish I could shoot you.
I wish I could make you have a sweet, sweet nap.
A lifetime of...
of peace and quiet.
Turn around!
Go away!
What are you just standing there for?
What are you daydreaming there?
Dummy!
That guy will turn around.
Um, definitely before Yeah, there we go.
Okay.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
There we go.
To the president!
Riden is so saucy.
I know, right?
Oh, my God.
Colonel?
It's too quiet.
Riden, the president should be somewhere in Strut B, where
you are now.
Okay.
is in danger hurry right um i think my life is in danger
colonel uh it's quiet ah
colonel oh colonel it's really spooky here reminds me of mgs
one i know
it looked like i gasped for ride and
Uh-oh.
It's kind of spooky here.
Those hips.
I know, man.
Grabbable.
Don't get caught.
Don't get caught, Raiden.
They're gonna do the job.
These guys.
Let them handle it.
They won't get killed.
They're better than the other guys.
Oh!
I can't hear them!
Oh.
They're...
They're not weak!
They won't give in!
This guy, he's the chosen one!
He's the main character!
Hell live!
Uh...
Bro, just...
Ah!
Oh no!
Oh!
Just shoot!
Just shoot him!
It's morbid time.
Morpheus!
Oh.
Ballet.
Oh!
No!
Ah!
Oh, that's gross.
Oh my god.
Okay, we're really playing it up now, huh?
Okay, it's just a fountain.
My goodness.
Please!
Just fall already!
Are you sure this is alpha?
It's like you...
I think you instead sent in the baby squad.
Alpha where?
Raiden, be careful.
I'm scared for you.
He's gonna come after your body.
Oh!
what's happening oh there's bugs oh sorry those are bullets
never mind oh my god oh my god he's twitching I think he's
enjoying it get sucked oh you know what it's you oh my god
he's a vampire here he's gonna do something really freaky I
He's gonna do something really freaky here, I bet.
Oh, oh, oh, oh my God.
What a freak!
Five today.
Or robbers.
Wow, vamp.
He really is a vampire!
Look at that smirk.
Ah!
Nosferatu.
Oh my god, Ryden, please.
What beautiful eyes this soldier has.
Where is he?
I don't know.
Probably.
Oh gosh, wow, this soldier even has such a nice butt.
Is everybody on this series have a nice butt?
Oh, God.
Ah!
Ooh, la la.
Strange smell.
They're smelling like a barker.
Aiden Jaeger.
You smell like...
A barker.
It has to be.
It has to be what?
Shoot him.
What are you waiting for?
Yeah, what are you waiting for?
Yeah, I know how to do the hanging, the grip strength.
Don't worry.
Yes, but wait till I tell you what I found.
Ooh, yes, queen.
I'll tell you a person.
Where are you?
In the central unit with the president.
Oh, central unit.
Oh, you're too slow, Raiden.
You're too slow.
Vamp is...
so OP like
that's kind of unfair hold on I'm not an enemy calm down
my name is my name is my name is Slim Shady that's what he
almost said he was quoting the song my name is Slim Shady
How did
you get in?
Fast rope descent from a Navy chopper.
Ew!
Wait, we saw those bugs before?
Have I seen you before?
Stop staring at his crotch, Plissken!
Are you Foxhound?
That's right.
Foxhound was disbanded.
Huh?
Where were you before Foxhound?
Delta Force?
Oh my god.
Plisket is so handsome.
I was part of the Army's Force 21 trials.
Force 21.
That's about tactical IT deployment, right?
Wow, real people!
That was me.
Not really.
That's me.
I've had extensive training, the kind that's
indistinguishable from the real thing.
Like what?
Video game.
Sneaky mission 60.
advanced VR huh advanced realistic in every way no no a
virtual grunt of the digital age that's just great I play a
video game more effective than live exercises you don't get
injured in VR do you every year a few soldiers die oh my god
VR missions there's pain sensation in VR and even a sense of
reality and urgency the only difference is it isn't actually
happening you're getting injured to remove from the fear
that goes with battle situations war is a video game what
better way to raise the ultimate soldier
no i think i should hold on to that i don't write it so
you're saying that vr training is some kind of mind control
oh what a funny time what's going on what's going on the
alpha team from navy seal 10 is dead no a single survivor
the kids wired with nano machines
what about the president looks like they took him somewhere
else i see you said there was a survivor from seal team 10.
yeah lieutenant j g pliskin has he seen your face j j
pliskin this is a top secret mission no one can know that
we're involved whatever too late for that
Oh, I don't turn away from there.
Take a look.
What is it?
Oh!
Oh my god.
What the hell?
A navy captain.
Oh!
Ow!
Pliskin!
You alright?
Pliskin, are you okay?
Give me a few minutes.
It's my...
It's my Twitter header.
a few more pints than I thought.
I want you to know your old chocomint cover is a banger.
Thank you.
That blood-sucking freak?
That was Vamp.
Vamp.
He's Romanian.
A wizard with knives, as you saw.
The way he moved didn't seem human.
You won't see that in VR, I guarantee.
What is he?
One of the members of Dead Cell.
Yeah!
Him?
A special forces unit created by ex-president George Sears.
The name was originally intended to reflect its
anti-terrorist functions.
All my favorite people.
The unit would launch unannounced assaults on government
complexes for the ultimate terrorism simulation.
They were needed to show VR troopers like you how to deal
with the real thing.
But around the time their original leader died in prison,
the unit began to unravel.
George Sears.
They were always close to the edge, but they became more and
more extreme.
Began to go after US allies and civilians.
We estimate that no fewer than a hundred people died as a
the dead cell arranged on their own they were out of control
and it all came to a head six months ago they fixed George
yeah the unit was devastated there are only three left now
you just saw one of them why would they go after the big
shell how should I know I told you they were on the lunatic
fringe what about their leader he says he's solid snake oh
snake died two years ago you mean the incident that made
this big shell necessary in the first place right and he but
he's a legend legends are usually bad news there's not a lot
of difference between heroes and madmen you're saying snake
is still alive and pulled another one you and snake have
similar thought process his body was positively IDed two
years ago snake is definitely dead solid snake solid snake
is definitely dead I'm buried what about the other soldiers
I saw Russian equipment too former Soviet military They're
probably mercenaries The big shell is too much ground for
just dead cell members to hold down Rips you weren't briefed
on any of this I know came in alone to boot Why why What are
you really doing here riding?
I come.
He's got to save the president can't tell me, huh?
Oh, fine with me
I don't smoke Keep it anyway.
May come in handy.
Ooh, like a little snack.
Take this too.
Yay!
Pliskin, you're so kind.
Do you have a suppressor, too?
I mean...
Come in, Alpha Zero.
This is Bravo Zero.
Currently at the bridge between Struts B and C.
The president is...
Damn, I can't hit this thing.
Not really good at stealth games.
Sometimes kind of frustrating you have with me.
Do you have any spoiler-free tips to get good?
Aren't you going to answer him?
I'm not good either.
Oh, I don't think you need to answer them.
The BC connecting bridge.
We need to get there.
Can you handle it?
I need a few more minutes.
Remember my frequency.
It's 141.80.
141.80.
Eight zero on this plant's layout if you need information on
the place or about dead cell contact me.
Okay You're using nano communication, right?
Yeah, but I can patch into your frequency Why you look so
sussy One for one point eight zero.
Hey, what's your name?
Riden Riden strange code name makes up for the boring one my
parents gave me Ooh.
Maybe I'll find out someday.
Pliskin's so cool!
Yeah!
He's so cool!
Why does Pliskin look so familiar?
You think so?
He doesn't look all that familiar to me, eh?
Maybe you're mistaking him for like another character.
Oh wait, uh...
Wait.
1.141.80.
He's asleep?
Wake up, Liskit!
He just needed a little nap.
Oh, he's my baby.
My baby.
Look at him.
Oh, he's just so cute.
Wait.
His sleeping face.
He's so cute.
I wish I had my camera.
Oh my god, I wish I had my camera.
Can I get closer?
Good morning, Puskin.
How much longer is this guy gonna sleep?
Good morning, Pliscan.
Psst, pst, pst.
Good morning.
Wish I were that relaxed.
What?
Pliscan!
He's still sleeping.
What did he just say?
Liquid.
Did he just say, Meryl?
asleep.
Oh my god, his little baby face.
Oh gosh, I'm obsessed.
I'm obsessed.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
Let's get out of here.
Yay!
Yeah, how does Pliskin... Meryl's a common name, you guys.
That's probably, like, a different Meryl, you know?
It's probably, like, a really funny coinkidink, though.
You know?
It's pretty funny.
Pretty funny coinkidink, I'd say.
Oh, we gotta get the M9.
Didn't someone say that the M9 was on, um...
Was on a... Oh, that's not a door.
The other... On F.
The F area.
Did you hear that?
How funny.
Oh, you have one.
Rosh.
Statue of Liberty.
I love being...
Gaze it in!
Thank you for saying mine.
Can you shoot him?
Yeah, but I don't want to lose health.
He's going to shoot me back.
You all know this.
You just want to watch me get my butt wiped.
It is kind of worth it, though, isn't it?
Open up.
No!
which one is this oh bc is that where we need to go where
did it wait where did you hear it you hear
it i hear it i i'm
gonna go back and see if i can get the m9 if it's actually
on the other um where you guys said it was the uh f f f f f
i'm sure it's nothing Yeah, strat F.
Yeah, yeah.
Sure, it's nothing.
Nothing here.
I'm sure it's...
Sure, it's nothing.
Are those guys still here?
They have to be, right?
Okay.
Woof, that was close.
We'll level up eventually.
I might even do it off-stream.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh, wait.
This is kind of bad, isn't it?
Uh-oh.
He's gonna turn around.
And I'm not gonna have any grip left.
Wait.
Uh...
Go, go, go, go, go!
We got this.
We're a god.
The president's package can wait.
Oh my god.
That camera, the security camera scared me.
It was this one, right?
Oh, I guess so.
Mint us to do the grip exercises all over again because of
the new character.
I was beginning to say I might do it off stream.
Just guys, you know.
Get exploded.
Anything down here?
I see something.
Nice shot.
Thank you.
I could do it here, actually.
I could do it right here.
Everybody ready?
A one.
A two.
Three!
Four!
Five!
Six!
Eight!
Nine!
Ten!
Eleven!
Twelve!
Thirteen!
Fourteen!
Oop!
I don't know if that counted.
Fifteen!
Sixteen!
Seventeen!
Eighteen!
Nineteen!
Twenty!
Twenty-one!
Tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick We're almost a quarter of the
way.
Counting with Minto.
22.
Wait, 23?
I don't know if the...
24!
25!
I don't know if the 21 counted.
26!
27!
28!
I don't know if the last ones count.
Wow, I'm just gonna count it anyway.
30!
32!
If you drop then quickly grab it'll count as 10.
No way, really?
Oh, drop.
Just kidding.
Oh!
Wait, how do I...
Okay, hold on.
No, are you pulling my leg?
I kind of want to test it, though.
How do you do it, though?
Oh, you need to catch onto a lower ledge.
Oh, okay, okay.
I was going to say, I don't think that's possible to catch
it that quickly.
It needs to be ledges.
What number are we at?
Something.
35, 36, 37, 38.
39...
40...
Stop giving me random numbers!
We're almost halfway there.
41!
42...
43...
44...
45...
46...
47!
Oh, I'm sorry, Brian.
Get up, Brian.
It's the sound he makes.
48, I think.
49!
50!
51.
52, 53, 54.
Right and hanging in midair, 55, 56, 57, 58, 59,
60, 61.
Nice.
Come on, guys.
63.
Count with me.
64.
65.
66.
68.
We all know what comes after 68.
What comes after?
after 68 everyone 69 72
73 74 75 oh my gosh we're so close 76
you guys we're so close 77 look at this view 78 79.
80.
20 more.
81.
Yeah, lift yourself up, bad boy.
Don't stop.
You can do it.
What was I at?
87 88 89 oh my gosh oh my gosh wait i was gonna do 90 but
close to me thanks for the being funny number achieved we're
so close we're so close we're so close 90 91 92 we're in the
home stretch 93 94!
95!
96!
So close, so close, so close, so close.
Four more, four more, four more!
Four!
Three!
Two!
One!
Yeah.
Ryden, your grip has gotten stronger.
Guess your hard work has paid off.
Jack, you're great.
Thank you.
Okay, I'm fine.
This one's for you, Rose.
So when is the mint workout video?
Wait, which way should I go?
Up or down?
I don't even know where this leads.
Strut F.
Warehouse.
Oh, the warehouse.
Oh.
I hate this area.
Wait, no.
I hate this area more than anything.
Nothing here.
Please don't make me go in here.
Wait a second.
Please.
I hate this area.
There it is.
We got it!
We can leave!
This is the worst strut.
I hate this room.
I hate this room more than anything in my afterlife.
Is he coming back?
Okay, I'm just gonna run for it.
We can leave.
I don't think anyone likes this room.
We'll come back to it.
needed what's on the bottom side though wait oh it's still
gone nice
is there anything down here that i can get let's see real
quick there's so much loot in that straw i know there is i
know nothing here
nothing here oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god Yep.
Nothing here.
Okay.
We'll come back.
Because it probably will be us just fumbling around.
There was already like a level 3 door.
I know I wouldn't be able to get into.
Nothing here.
Dun, dun.
Let's see.
Oh!
I just realized.
I might have to end soon.
Oh, no.
I'm not doing this again.
Yeah!
Um.
I think we'll call it in a second.
Let's get to the next area.
Because I do have a thing I need to do in an hour.
So.
Now we can just take these guys out.
Little baby.
Good night.
Hello.
I wish I could throw them overboard.
Should be able to.
Nothing here.
What do you got?
Anything?
What you got?
What kind of snacks you have?
Nothing?
You cheap?
Cheapo!
It's been really fun already.
I'm glad!
I love this game so much.
Oh, I wonder if Pliskin's still asleep.
Do these guys have anything?
Why can't I pick up their stuff?
Pick up your gun at least.
Hey, take it.
It's free loot!
What if I put him to sleep even more?
I think you can shoot that thing.
Sorry.
Good night.
It was... It's not even...
It's a... It's... You know...
It's... It's not even a...
It was a Dracula!
Always ready.
That's my god.
I Pliskin is just so cool
What's going on out here?
Snake no, no, no, that's Pliskin.
I think you're confusing him He's so cool.
He's like snake, but that's oh my god here.
Come Ah, I love this fire
Fortune oh my god, she's so cool.
Watch this guy Watch this.
Watch this.
Nothing hits her.
Oh my god, the president!
We're just all shooting so willy-nilly at the president
lying there.
Oh my god, she's so hot.
I love Fortune's theme.
Whoa.
It's all just...
What the hell is that?
It's just flying around her.
Oh my god.
Come, put me out of my misery.
This is impossible.
Nothing will hit her.
Is she the one they call fortune?
Oh, lady luck.
Ooh.
I can't believe they're just like, yeah, we're gonna shoot.
Even though the president's just like lying there.
Forget Rose.
This is a lady.
Queen.
Don't let them take the president!
Mr. President!
Oh my god.
Ready grenades!
Here it comes.
A dud!
Uh-oh.
Today is another bad day.
She's so awesome.
Is there anyone here that can give me happiness?
She's so awesome!
Me,
queen!
Me, I can give you happiness!
Choose me!
She's so awesome.
Oh my god, she's so awesome.
Oh wow.
Are you gonna spare him?
Brother!
Mufasa!
Help me, brother!
Long live!
Ah!
No!
I'm so sorry, my beauties.
I'll see you again someday.
She's so close.
Colonel, SEAL Team 10's Bravo team was wiped out.
I see.
What happened to the cargo choppers?
Both of them are at the bottom of the harbor.
Looks like your new hosts have a Harrier too.
A Harrier?
What is this?
Calm down.
It just means they anticipated the attack.
Besides, since the SEALs drew their fire, your infiltration
went off without a hitch.
On top of that, we know their defensive capabilities.
saying this was all a faint right get a hold of yourself the
entire mission is in your hands now do you understand no
pressure there's no time for questions they could decide to
retaliate for that failed assault you mean the hostages they
could be in danger yes but we need to consider the
possibility that they'll blow the whole shell if that toxic
spell does take place it'll devastate not only the harbor
but poison the coastline for generations oh my god we've had
to adjust the mission objectives the priority is now on
removing those c4s of the terrorists wired over the big
shell the president can wait but this can't the president
can wait you know I'm no bomb disposal expert that's not a
problem the Bravo team brought an explosives pro in with
them oh let's go he was supposed to stand by on Strut C
according to their mission plan you in there is this
according to simulation too what are you talking about get
to stretch see and find understood but I need to ask you
something before I go this is just like my video games who
are shut the hell up dead cell I mean they couldn't hit her
no matter how hard they tried and that vampire too it's like
it's like being in a nightmare you can't wake up from Jack
snap out of it and you Rose I can't believe you're on this
mission I keep thinking I'll wake up is real and that's why
you won't wake up but nothing seems real i've made up my
mind to stay with you whether this is real or a bad dream
i'll keep watching you till it's over thank you rose and i
won't let you be just a dream are you two done right you're
needed on strut c kernel has no kernel is so no nonsense
it's just like ryan asks him something and he's just like
what are what the hell are you talking about man He's like,
shut up.
Shut the hell up.
Shut up, Ryden.
Ryden's already done with Ryden.
He doesn't even want to deal with him.
Glad we got to see a dud.
Colonel's too old for this, it's true.
No chill colonel.
Oh, I like this place.
Because that's the bathroom.
Actually, I don't remember.
Oh, that scared me.
Oh, yeah!
Lady Liberty!
Ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-say.
Can you see?
USA!
By the door!
Jack, is that you?
Don't.
They were jorking it in the bathroom.
And by it, I mean...
I mean my M9.
Jack, when you get home, let's have a homecoming party.
Just the two of us.
She just raises every...
That's a good idea.
Ew.
I'll make dinner.
Why are they so...
what's wrong well that sounds good but how about we eat out
this rose is cooking bad you know the place that we went to
recently with the amazing lobster i really like that place
well yeah i guess that's okay too whoo nothing i just love
lobster yeah can't wait woohoo well then i'll make a
reservation promise me you'll come back safely maybe don't
worry raising every Every red flag, every death flag ever.
I wish I were that relaxed.
Pushkin, wake up!
I almost made a mistake, sorry.
I wish I was that relaxed.
Does this turn on?
It does.
Look at me, handsome devil.
Watch this.
Oh,
hold on, watch this, watch this, watch this.
Oh, uh...
Damn, I can't...
Wait, hold on.
Let me see if I can do it now.
No, I can only crouch.
I was gonna try... Wait, maybe I could do this.
No.
Never mind.
Wash your hands.
I didn't go to the bathroom.
Rose, I'm in the girl's bathroom!
I'm smelling in here.
What can I do for you, Jack?
I'm at the girl's bathroom.
girls shadow boxing i'm shadow boxing in the girls bathroom
what are you gonna do what do you how do you feel about that
rose how do you feel about that how do you feel about that
how do you feel about that i can't believe you jack do you
know what that place is i just thought maybe the bomb
disposal instructor might be in there why would he be in
there well you never know he's awol and even AWOL a normal
guy wouldn't go into a woman's bathroom you're the only one
I know who would you're like really strange rosemary settle
down but it's all right right you should probably look
someplace else I've never heard that one before what sir
nothing right that's that's that return to your duties that
was even the negative reaction too that was so funny that
was the reaction someone said press l2 and r2 while i'm
while i'm looking at myself wow what a stance this guy has
you never know see there's bandages oh sorry uh pisismine in
here why is there pisismine in the bathroom what an
egotistical woman oh i can't wait to hear that line it's my
favorite one you guys I think, see, this is why I consider
two of my favorite.
I just am always quoting it.
I can't stop quoting this stupid series.
I can't stop quoting it.
Bip-bip.
Hey, man, you're like really strange.
MGS2 has good quotes.
It really does.
The brain rooms are so...
Ah!
Yippee!
freeze don't shoot he's our man I think probably you a cop
I'm not NYPD I came in with the Bravo team who are you with
and what happened to seal team 10 I have some bad news for
you yeah all of them all of them they threw a dud you don't
understand did I tell you you could It's alright.
He's not one of the bad guys.
Pliskin, you scared me.
I thought you were napping.
Don't go pointing that thing everywhere, kid.
What's your name?
My name is Peter.
Peter Stilman!
Lecturer at Nav Scolio at Indian Head.
Also a consultant for the NYPD Bomb Squad.
A poor old man who got dragged along for this picnic.
Peter.
I thought you'd retired.
I did.
Can't keep up with everybody.
As you can see.
Oh my god, Peter.
Thinking of Hunger Games now.
A famous church got wiped off the map thanks to me.
Too many lives inside.
All I lost was this leg.
His guilt.
So you the bomb disposal guy.
Ryden?
Stop.
Ryden, you are...
Your sass is off the meter.
Kid, this is the bomb disposal guy.
Open any explosives disposal textbook and you'll see his
name.
This guy's talking about...
Like just ancient history now lost his leg and all these
people died.
He's just why did they bring you out of retirement then
because the terrorists Here includes one of my students
right in a survey Fat man He was an atomic bomb when he was
only ten.
Oh I created him in a sense and that's why you're here.
Why did you help a ten-year-old create an atomic bomb?
Where didn't a ten-year-old get uranium from?
I wouldn't say that Um, how?
Where did he get it?
There are at least two people here who can claim to be
experts at bomb disposal.
They made it out of Legos.
Are you two with SEAL Team 10?
I didn't see you at the mission briefing.
Oh, we're with another squad.
My name is Pliskin, Lieutenant Junior Grade.
Honor to meet you, sir.
Mr. Pliskin, do you have any experience with explosives
disposal?
Don't worry about me.
And he looks young, but he can do it.
But we need more manpower.
I'm...
What's your name?
That's an odd name.
Why does everybody say that?
There was also an engineer with me.
An engineer?
A skinny guy.
He went in with us.
Not a fat man.
Skinny guy.
Where is he?
I haven't seen him since that skirmish.
Was he killed?
I don't think so.
I didn't find his body.
I see.
They told me he was a security systems architect for the big
shell.
Why would they take a civilian along?
Everything in this structure is computer controlled.
He was supposed to get us past all the security measures.
I never heard anything about that.
He had official orders with him.
Hmm.
We'll leave that for later.
Right now we need to figure out how to deal with all the
bombs.
Who could it be?
Skinny Guy.
Yep.
So we have to do it ourselves.
Batman vs.
Skinny Guy.
But I've never defused a bomb before.
Hold on a sec.
Off to confer with the CO again.
Hey.
um yeah i'm a i'm glad to hear stillman is safe i'm a system
in any way possible to clear the c4 from the structure
colonel you know i've never been trained in bomb disposal
yeah it's all right the man you're working with is the best
in the field all you have to do is follow his directions you
will of course keep your identity and mission objectives to
yourself is it true that an engineer came in with stillman
why does riding like go off the screen it's probably
something the seals decided on their own hmm there are more
important issues at handwriting the enemy may retaliate for
the failed assault think you are get those c4s neutralized
now okay I'm not qualified for bomb disposal Jack it's me oh
Rose you can do this I'm trust me you haven't had bomb
disposal training per se in VR but you're more than capable
of handling c4 this is a little different from using c4
you're up for this you know that how about it kid are the
results in yet pliskin and filter infiltrating my thoughts
300 video games by the way to think about this so much yeah
you think that they would give him something be dismantling
the bomb something about that's not for amateurs but we'll
try here instead is a temporary freezing measure ah look at
this okay i'm looking
Could you move it any slower?
This is a C4 bar.
Please move it slower.
I'm scared.
It's live.
You can see it pulsing.
Now you spray this on the sucker and...
There we go.
Simple, huh?
The spray freezes the detonator instantly.
Yippee!
How long does the effect last?
There's no way the thing can detonate in this condition.
Nice.
Even if you leave it alone, it'll stay out of commission for
at least 24 hours.
Okay.
That is enough time.
If we had the manpower, I'd recommend complete disposal
instantly.
I know right?
I would instantly is a bit of a way I'll check the floor
ceiling walls under a table everywhere try to imagine the
locations the bomber would choose That won't be easy.
We don't know a thing about fat man.
Is there anything that'll help us locate the bombs?
I love that man.
Here take this with me.
We know one thing.
It's what they call an ion mobility spectrometer It can
recognize ionized gas emitted by C4s.
Ooh.
Oh stinky That little gadget snips out C4's scent.
That's right.
I've established a link up with your radar network.
So any scented technique will represent a vision.
Have the sensor activated and keep your eye on the radar.
I really like Fat Man.
What if he's using some other odorless substance?
He's so awesome.
Sniffy sniffy sniffy.
I know Fat Man well.
I know how into his own aesthetics he is.
Signatures?
Yes.
On every bomb he builds, he always leaves a trace.
of the clone he uses.
Ooh, Fatima.
The censer also picks up that particular scent spectrum.
Is that something he learned from you?
No, it was his own quirk.
He's just quirky like that.
Except his own.
And he followed them like a religion.
And common sense wasn't one of his strong points.
I thought I taught him everything I knew.
I have no children of my own.
And I thought I found a son in him.
He had the right stuff, you know.
There's something very unusual.
about an ability like that.
Yeah, the portrait's real good.
Yeah, so awesome.
I remember some people called him one of the fat cats.
Fat cats.
Maybe that's what started all this.
He's not a cat, I'm a man.
There are some things you have to pass on.
The trick is to know which one.
All I taught him was skills.
I don't know if you should teach anybody skills on how to
make a bar.
I wonder if, you know, God, watermelon.
Let's see how well that sensor works.
Oh, it's a watermelon.
I'm activating them.
Watch.
Okay.
You see the green stuff on the radar?
That's a visual representation of the C4 scent detected by
the sensor.
It's a pretty big area, isn't it?
Don't complain.
It's better than nothing.
Just activate the sensors and search here.
How can we not smell it?
All right.
Why don't we just use our nose?
I think Batman and Running Man would have cooperated another
time.
I think so.
We have to keep out of the enemy's sight, too, because the
radar gets knocked offline when we're spotted.
Fat Man is against running, though.
Fat Man would have allotted some C4s here in Strut C as
well.
He's too cool.
Smello vision.
I know the structure of this facility, and if he wants to
take out the plant, where he would target.
You know this for sure?
Of course.
I taught him the techniques he uses.
His ideas are based on my theories.
Demolition is a kind of ideology.
It makes no exception to time of place.
Big shell consists of two hexagons joined in on in, north to
south.
There should be packets of C4s on each of the vertices, or
the struts in this case.
You need at least that to take a building of this integrity
out.
Is that the flag?
Six on shell one.
Another six on shell two.
A total of 12 bombs at least.
Considering the shell's architecture and composition from an
engineering standpoint, that's my conclusion.
And it's exactly what he would have decided as well.
Hmm.
Okay.
Where'd they put the halfpipes?
Yeah.
Kid, this place is all yours.
I'll take care of Shell too.
Okay.
Take this.
What are you giving me?
What is it?
Oh!
Level!
What's this?
What?
personnel i like the idea of using hints to find the bombs
like a game of hot cold bed security layout includes varying
levels of clearance oh i hate that room the clearance level
is identified by the number printed on these doors no
writing your card key can open doors for security clearance
level one no pliskin your card can get you into level three
this isn't messed up to get next door to shell two why can't
i why did you get this that engineer i told you about gave
it to me you're supposed to program a set of all excess cars
once we were on sight unfortunately this card won't get you
into every area of this structure damn pliskin is better
you're right we'll have to deal with the remaining security
lockouts as they come up i don't even know why i'm trying to
go hey hey where you think you're going mister yeah no i'm
going no sir the two of us can handle it don't worry but
yeah you'll just slow us down with that leg of yours you
don't have to be so honest there's a war going on here I
don't have time to babysit anymore.
Just to hide in the fridge.
Why don't you just let us handle the grunt work?
You can tell us what to do over the radio like in the
original mission plan.
Alright.
I'll give you instructions from here.
I may also need to prepare a backup plan just in case.
In case of what?
Good luck to both of you.
This is a dangerous one.
Go out the exit from the kitchen.
You'll see a cessbox.
Wins.
Oh, okay, I'll check.
If anything comes up, let me know.
Okay.
My frequency is 1-4-0.25.
1-4-0.
Good luck, kid.
I'll see you later.
Semper Fi.
That man's no seal.
I don't even think he's a navy man.
What?
Oh.
He's so safe.
Semper Fi.
Marine Corps talk.
Ooh.
Semper Fi.
Why did he even think to say that?
Normally team leaders stay in the CP and give orders with
those headphones.
And as far as I know, seals keep their officers away from
the field.
Seperify.
And who dares win is a model of the pretty special air
service.
Nailed it.
Is he one of the terrorists then?
They don't suspect a thing.
If there's someone to suspect, I'd put my money on you.
Hey, what do you mean by that?
I'm is it because I'm so beautiful I'm I'm right enough just
take care of those bombs for now okay what about you they
could be back in this area soon you hide in there I'll hide
out in this pantry for a while if I lock the door should be
alright yeah plenty of food in here too so you don't need to
worry about me.
But our bathroom.
I'll give you instructions by Kodak from here.
Do you need to go potty first?
Good luck, kid.
Hi!
Oh.
Bomb disposal is a face-off with your own mortality.
Don't let the fear get to you.
When you give in to the fear, why would it have a lock?
Because...
Well, actually, it's weird why it would have a lock on the
inside.
Having a lock on the outside makes sense because you don't
want people getting into the pantry.
But Why would I have one on the inside?
Hmm.
Okay.
Nice.
Pliskin went this way, right?
Did he go this way?
So the food doesn't get out?
So you aren't locked in.
But then people can just unlock it from the...
Oh.
Ah!
What
is this?
What is this?
Call him?
Pliskin!
I see the old man set you up with a Sensor A unit.
Aside from C4, explosives continually release their own
specific particles.
Yeah, he told us all about this.
Based on ion mobility spectrometry technology, Sensor A is
capable of detecting particle clusters.
Simply put, the detector can sniff out C4.
No way!
The detected C4 appears on radar as a cloud-like shape.
The cloud indicates the rough location of the explosive.
No, the orange!
This sensor looks like it's been specially tuned.
It's been specially modified to sniff out the signature odor
of C4, combined with Fat Man's special perfume that he uses
to identify his work.
That's why it won't respond to any of the C4 that we've set
up.
I know, we literally told us all about it.
Puskin, I just saw someone with a box!
Tell me a little more about Dead Cell.
Dead Cell was a shadow unit within the SEALS organization.
I just saw a box!
They handled surprise raids on vital government facilities,
didn't they?
Yes, they were originally put together to check the nation's
military security system.
The unit was the brainchild of ex-president George Sears.
Dead Cell was a secret unit positioned at the opposite end
of anti-terrorist outfits, such as Delta Force and SEALS.
a group of madmen yeah no they got weird when Colonel
Jackson fortune's husband was sent to jail sent to jail for
what corruption he misappropriated government funds sounds
like he deserved it that's what everybody else thought
except for the members of dead cell they felt the colonel
was falsely accused fact is they took the case to the powers
that be but they never managed to reopen the Yes.
Was there any truth to their claim?
Yes.
Who knows?
Whatever the situation is.
Dead Cell's name was tainted.
And Colonel Jackson?
He was being held at Leavenworth.
Was.
Meaning he's been released?
Well, in a manner of speaking, the Colonel's dead.
Apparently, he lost the will to live and died in prison.
The members of Dead Cell snapped with the loss of their
leader.
They underwent a radical change and became uncontrollable.
That's a way to put it.
And that's why they undertook this terrorist operation.
Seems as good a reason as any.
Dead.
BROING!
VAMP is a member of Dead Cell.
Born in Romania, his specialty is knives.
But I guess you know that by now.
When he was just a kid, he lost his family to a terrorist
bomb that went off in a church they were attending.
His body pierced by a crucifix, VAMP was buried under the
rubble for two days before he was finally rescued.
During those two days, he survived by feeding on the blood
of his family to quench his thirst.
that was how he acquired a taste for blood so that's why
they call him vamp no vamp isn't for vampire it's because
he's bisexual rumor has it vamp was the lover of scott doll
the marine common dodge who accidentally died two years ago
scott doll was also the father of fortune the dead cell
leader fortune's old man but fortune and vamp you noticed
hey not bad for a rookie all right as you say vamp and
fortune are very close not lovers but very close friends no
there's more to their relationship that but vamp was her
father's lover would it have been better if it was with her
mother well I don't really think they care what you think
focus on the mission by the way have you ever met the guy
before I don't understand the correlation they seem to know
I don't know why right well why he's so matter-of-factly
it's just like no it's because he's fine i told you the dead
cell is a group of madmen i wouldn't take anything they say
very seriously are you a vampire maybe maybe i'm more
vampire than ghost than i thought what do you know about
that strange woman you mean fortune she's the dead cell
leader come on i want the box i think we missed the box
codec that's so sad
got the name because bullets seem to veer away from her in
battle people have heard her say that her fortune in battle
was payback for the lousy luck she's had in life lousy luck
the death of her father the marine commander the conviction
of husband i like listening to him anyway these events were
followed by her mother's suicide the loss of a husband and
the idea of a convict in the family apparently took her over
the edge lady luck but she's not very lucky at the time and
the shock of her mother's death led to the loss of her
child.
Oh my god!
Add to this her husband's death in prison a few months
later, and to sum it up, in the six months after her
father's death, she lost her family and everything that
mattered in her life.
Jeez, she's had it rough.
Yeah, the thing is, she didn't grieve long.
Instead, she joined the military.
Now why is that?
Revenge, baby.
Do I look psychic?
My best guess is revenge.
Yeah.
I heard that she firmly believed that her husband was
framed.
Do I look psychic?
Bliskin is so sassy.
By the time she came out of basic training, she'd proven
many times over that she was gifted with an unusual streak
of luck.
Oh my god, sassy, Bliskin.
Some say she sold her soul for it.
Her soul?
Her uncanny luck earned her a reputation that led to her
appointment as the head of her husband's unit, Dead Cell.
Hmm.
What else do you have to say to us, Pliskin?
Fat man.
Yeah!
Supposedly he's nicknamed after an atomic bomb, but to me,
he's just a fat man.
something straight out of a sideshow if he even has a bit of
spare time he spends it disassembling and assembling his
glock over and over again what are you trying to say you
can't stand to have his hands still he's extremely vain
about his hands keeps his fingers as slender and soft as a
woman's they say he's always looking at his hands giving
himself manicures that man is so eccentric I I love him.
Quiskin, I saw someone wearing a cardboard box just now.
A box?
I don't know anything about that.
Are you sure you weren't imagining things?
Of course I'm sure.
Do you think it's one of the members of Dead Cell?
How should I know?
I don't want to fight someone like that.
Why not?
Because it looks so dumb.
Anyone who's willing to be seen like that must be completely
insane.
What the?
I mean, he's a psycho.
There's no question about it.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Pliskin,
what do you know about Stilman?
He's a bomb disposal expert.
Probably the best in the world.
What else?
What do you mean?
Like why he retired.
Are you here to gossip?
No.
Then get back to work diffusing those C4s.
If there's something you need to know about Stilman, go ask
him yourself.
the two five
you're to gossip it appears that fat man placed bombs within
each of the struts it's likely there are no bombs planted on
the connecting bridges head for the struts for what you have
not yet finished disposing of the sea four six and nine yay
oh the little piece of the box I'm sorry Pliskin I'm sorry I
broke your box oh okay this guy is oh shit Um, um, um, um,
um, um, um,
um, oh, oh, that was close.
That was too close.
Let's, uh, let's go back inside.
Okay.
That was way too close.
How nice of that guard to wave through your whole codec
call.
Sheesh.
Is there anybody in here?
Can we go around?
Oh, I can go through here now, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Um, because I gotta go.
You guys, I've got to go.
Jack, do you need to save?
I do!
And we got all the codec stuff, so it should save that.
Yay!
Hang in there.
Oh.
That's it?
That's all you gotta tell me, Rose?
That's all?
That's it?
That's all you gotta tell me?
Nothing else?
Okay.
Sure.
Before you go, did you work out the eternal darkness save
issue?
I did!
I did, I did, I did.
Yeah.
Um...
Thank you, thank you!
Two!
Viralyn, thank you!
Thanks for another MGS Saturday just letting you know that
you have gotten so much better at being sneaky.
Ah!
Really?
You think so?
Thank you!
I'm still scared for the rest of the game.
Do you remember what day it is tomorrow?
I don't know.
I'm just a silly guy.
Bomb disposal?
Diffusion?
I don't know.
what day it is tomorrow.
I don't know anything.
I'm silly.
I'm just a silly guy.
For the next time I play this, I believe I will be playing
it on Thursday.
Thursday because I will be busy on next Saturday.
So I'm sorry because I feel bad the previous Metal Gear was
when I finished Metal Gear Solid 1.
It was on a weekday.
It wasn't a Saturday.
And then next one will not be a either in fact I think I
think honestly my next couple of Saturdays are gonna be kind
of busy so I thought I could I even considered I was like
hmm maybe I should uh maybe I shouldn't start Metal Gear
until my my weekends are a little less busy but um we'll
still have Metal Gear at some point deja vu I've just been
in this place before So, um, yeah.
But, uh, so next Thursday we'll be playing more Metal Gear.
Spike!
Thank you for the tiny gift, and thank you!
Mm-mm.
And, um, yeah, so, my weekends coming up for the next couple
of weeks are, like, kind of insane.
Kind of crazy.
Um, but if I can, maybe I can make them Metal Gear Sundays.
If I can't do Saturday.
Sundays, I can't even do.
Oh, it's kind of complicated.
Mint Frenchman.
Hope for good reason.
Yeah, it's just like, like, not next weekend, but the
weekend after.
I'll be guesting at a convention in Texas.
I'll be seeing the Did You Know Gaming videos on Metal Gear
games.
They got David Hater to voice them too.
I have seen them, yeah.
I have, I have.
Mm-hmm.
MGS2 is always super comfy somehow?
Really?
I think so?
I think it's the most stressful game in the world.
Wow.
Comfy.
Yeah.
We're in Texas?
I'm sorry.
I don't have the information.
It's called Anime Fest, I believe.
So, hmm.
But yeah, don't work too hard.
Thank you.
Arlington?
Is it an Arlington?
Maybe Arlington, Texas.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, um, I do have some stuff that I need to take care of for
next weekend, actually, that I'm taking care of soon
tonight.
So, um, yeah.
Excited for Anime Fest.
It's so close to my house.
Oh, my God!
I'll see you there!
I hear this George Sears guy is pretty neat.
He is...
Solidus.
Welcome back.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, George Sears?
He's like the...
He's my president.
That's the best president.
I love that guy.
But yeah, thank you for part one of MGS2.
We will continue next week.
And we'll get all into the fun stuff.
It's just all beginning.
All the cool craziness is just starting.
So, yeah.
Thanks for such a great streaming.
Thank you!
Thank you guys for watching!
Thank you guys for hanging out, and I will see you guys!
I will be streaming tomorrow.
I'll try and get a waiting room up tonight.
I'm not quite sure what I'm doing yet.
I think I have two streams tomorrow, actually.
Well, one for Patreon.
And one on my channel.
Patreon for the podcast.
Okie dokie!
Atsuminto!
I'll see you guys tomorrow!
Bye-bye.
Thank you.